okay
good
morning what do we do got uh HB
1033 we have the sponsor
here and repr Gart
here I would say right out of the block
I noticed that it's in the wrong
RSA okay I don't know it was you told
them which RSA to be in or did you I
took the professional advice of
OSS and uh unfortunately we have a lot
of new people there okay go ahead thank
you good morning committee
representative Jason Gard representing
Northfield Franklin M Mike
25 this bill quite simply prohibits the
advertising of nominal dimensions of
lumber as some may or may not be aware a
2x4 that you buy in the store is not
actually 2 in by 4 in it's 1 and 1/2 by
3 and 1/2 and similarly
other Lumber is not what it is actually
represented to
be so for some examples let's say a 2X
12 it's 1 and 1/2 by 11 and A4 which
might seem minimal but let's go back to
the 2x4 that's a 25% reduction in what
you're actually buying so if you were to
buy a gallon of milk and you get three
quarts you would be pretty upset and
rightfully
so the reason I brought this bill
forward is because I'm a carpenter and I
work with wood all day long and I think
you should tell the truth and what
you're selling and it just simply puts
everybody on a Level Playing Field so
you know what you're getting and you can
compare easily the I'm I'm assuming one
of the arguments is that this is because
it's plain Down Smooth etc etc but when
you go to a rough cut lumber yard they
figured out the magical way of cutting a
2x4 to 2 in by 4 in if they were to so
choose to plane it down then advertise
it as
such I I it doesn't it doesn't seem that
complicated me to tell the truth and the
Bible tells us to tell the truth when it
comes to weights and measures so
Deuteronomy 25 13-16 you shall have you
shall not have in your bag differing
weights a heavy and a light you shall
not have in your house differing
measures a large and a small you shall
have a perfect and just measure that
your days may be lengthened in the land
which the Lord your God is giving you
and there other there other passages but
it's
basic truth that you should let people
know what you're selling so I don't know
to me it just seems very simple so maybe
I'm oversimplifying it um just a couple
more examples your deck boards they call
them five quarter on your deck they're
actually one inch I don't even know what
five quarter um and plywood is minimally
off so half inch is really 15 30 seconds
and 3/4s 23 30 seconds so that's pretty
minimal but still it's not right I'll
take any questions hopefully I can
answer them and yeah thank
you repr represent Aon
as a
frequent flyer with frequent flyer miles
at Home Depot myself uh have you ever
looked at the so where they very clearly
label the nominal dimensions and the
actual dimensions on what they're
selling MH so I could it it in my it
explain to me how this is different if I
go into a store and ask for a cola and
they give me a coke that the coal is the
generic name but I get a Coke and so
when I go into Home Depot and I buy a
piece of five quter board which I am
well advised of the fact that it's not
five qus of an
inch and they have it they say they
don't even call it five quarter board
there but if I get a piece of five quter
board trim they've clearly marked what
the actual dimensions are so is this a
labeling issue that you want stores to
label because in the case of most Lumber
yards that I'm familiar with in my area
they they do label it that way or is
this something you want to go back to
warehousing I'm not exactly sure you're
saying at the retail point the retail I
would say at the point of sale it should
say what you're buying does but it does
in these little itty bitty things when
you look online 2x4 it comes up and you
have to go into the specifications and
actually say oh oh there's the actual I
don't understand why we need that second
hurdle it just doesn't make any sense to
me that's what I'm trying to get at if
you have a product it's like saying this
is a yard but it's 2 feet no it's not a
yard it's 2 feet so but the little sign
in the fine print says this I I don't
see the necessity for it I'm
just okay fair enough re
H thank you for uh bringing this bill to
us it's a an interesting topic that you
brought up here um so I was always
taught uh you measure twice and you cut
once right so in that double measuring
you would find out the actual dimensions
of the board uh the way the way I was
told uh the reason for that is the raw
Lumber is 2 in and the width of the saw
is what knocks it down to less than two
inches uh is that your understanding I
don't believe that to be true because
then why would be variations happen so
for instance 2x4 1 and a half by 3 and a
half but now when you're doing the 2 x
12 it's only 11 and a quarter you know
what I mean it's not following the same
rate
so we can
yeah I'm just going to stick with what I
initially said if you're selling
something say what you're selling
otherwise don't say it it just I I think
that's a pretty much basic principle but
maybe I'm missing something okay
representa M thanks Mr chairman
philosophically we probably agree in
truth and advertising but on the Shelf
Edge price would you believe like the
the Shelf Edge I think that's the fine
print you're talking about at Home Depot
I've also noticed that it does say the
actual
dimensions and I'm guessing saying and
I'm wondering if you have any insight
they do that because of the average
uneducated home DIY consumer like me
that years ago may have thought I was
buying a 2x4 but they put it to make
sure I don't have to return it or I
don't get it you know I don't get it
wrong well I think they already label it
do they okay I didn't want to cut you
off actually there was a lawsuit so
somebody sued was it Lowe's and Home
whatever I think it was Lowe's and Home
Depot but they sued them saying that
they weren't sold the right wood and
blah blah blah and that's what that led
to a lot more of the explicit
advertising of
such um I okay going back to what we're
saying with do
yourselfers I think we should be
encouraging people to do more work on
their houses and I I don't it's I would
say it's kind of similar to the whole
lawyer I'd say scam but this legal ease
that most people don't understand so
we've created this separate language
that only the select understand now I
understand it's a minimal thing but
still shouldn't we all be speaking the
same language and when it comes to math
I yeah I don't know just seem so
straightforward it's hard to explain
when it's so representative Burrows
thanks for taking my question beyond the
lawsuit what evidence is there that this
is a problem that this is a problem for
people I would say not telling the truth
is a problem for everyone but do you
have any other evidence to back it how
do you know that that the consumers are
having a problem with this oh well I
mean if you could go that angle it would
be in that lawsuit they brought some
evidence forward they did some kind of
poll or something and the vast majority
of people don't know that a 2x4 is not
actually 2x4 who they PLL I don't know
maybe it's you know elementary school
kids I don't know but the point being is
most people actually don't realize that
because most people don't work on their
houses which I think is a really bad
thing I think well this a philosophical
thing I think you should build your own
house in a way because but yeah anyway
um it's a it's a deeper well I mean it
would it would make you appreciate it
anyway okay so oh we got more yes
represent
Spar I I've lived in a number of states
and I've seen these kind of measurements
everywhere I've lived and I do do I
don't my husband does a lot of work on
the houses that we've lived in and it
seems like it's a standard everywhere
we've lived to do this is this an
industry standard that they put the
measurements out that
way yes I mean Home Depot and lows are
international so not no long before
either one of them even started it's an
industry standard it's an industry
standard for the 1930s okay thank
you yeah so I guess I'd pick up there um
the only time we've ever had a bill
similar to your subject matter was um
Gary Daniels brought in when he was in
ref before was Senator but he brought in
a bill that was I didn't like the fact
that gas stations always charged that
you know that's
[Music]
2999 and he says well where's this 0.9 I
me you can't do 0.9 I mean 0.9 doesn't
exist but you know it's truth and
adverti let's fix this up and the end of
the day the problem is is that you're
actually going to create more
confusion if you were to pass this bill
because that for everyone
who's ever stumbled into a lumber ever
bought a
2x4 and maybe the very first time you
bought it you say boy that's annoying
that that 2x4 is not a
2x4 okay but it's just that's what it's
called and so what I'm going to ask you
is is think about it's not that that
they're being untruthful about what
they're selling because they're selling
their marketing it is is this is what
everybody thinks a 2x4 looks like that's
when if I go in for a 2X four I if I
haven't learned the first time I'll
learn soon enough that a 2x4 is not
truly a 2x4 unless I go buy it from my
next door neighbor Brian Damon who has
raw Lumber and and it really is truly a
2x4 I would I would simply say
that just okay the fact that something
goes on for a long time that's not
truthful doesn't make it truthful so I
would go back to let's say we go back to
the 30s for a second in the black Law
Dictionary dollar is defined as 120th an
ounce of gold now you need $2,000 or
more I don't even know what the rate is
right now to buy a dollar you know for
the equivalent goal
so to me telling the truth is important
not that I've always done it I've made
mistakes like all but I think getting
back to just simple math I mean okay we
haven't done this in a long time people
will be confused well you know what
being confused by the truth isn't being
confused now you know the truth so
that's all I gonna say on that and uh
yeah fair enough any other questions
representative
pelli I would be more interested in what
am I paying for so do you find that
there are pricing issues so everything
now is shrinkage right you don't get a
package of Oreos everything is shrunk so
is there an issue with the pricing
because they the boards are not actually
2x4s and they're charging you for 2x4 is
that a concern at all no I mean I I
don't even know how to answer that I
would just say that if as before just if
you're selling X have it to be X don't
so you need get the uh the c number you
questions okay great thank you thank
you okay okay the actual product
thickness is
really one and a half right right three
and a half right exactly so so it's
right okay uh so Jason stock from New
Hampshire Timberland Owners Association
which I think my neighbors a member of
your organization where I get my 2x4s
2x4s and in opposition to the
bill well well good morning um for the
record I'm Jason stock I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Timberland
Owners Association
our our members uh own Timberland they
also own Sawmills wood processing
facilities loggers Foresters
um and we have an interest in this bill
um we we as as the chairman had
mentioned we we oppose this bill I think
listening to the discussion you all have
kind of touched on a lot of the items
that really kind of raised the the red
flag for us um this is an industry
standard New Hampshire
Lumber in Lumber in general is is traded
internationally in fact New Hampshire we
have one of the largest Lumber trading
houses in nasua Seaboard International
one of the largest in the in the world
trading internationally softwood Lumber
and so you know to for New Hampshire and
we all love the state we all you know
it's important but if we were to create
our own Lumber standard the disruption
that would occur not only domestically
but potentially internationally if
you're trading uh 1x4s or 2x4s out of
the out of a New Hampshire Sawmill um
that would be that would be problematic
for us the other piece is we do
represent we do have members that have
portable sawmills representative MCU
actually had a chance to see one at our
annual meeting last year um and you know
I asked them about this bill and one of
the things they had told me you know
some concerns they raised is that you
know they'll sell green l
it is a solid 2 in by 4 in and the
expectation is as Lumber dries you're
going to get some shrinkage but also
you're going to um if you plan it when
you go to plan it you also so this this
concept of a nominal a nominal uh
Dimension takes into consideration those
facts that you have green Lumber yes at
one point in time it was in fact 2 in by
4 in it gets dried you get shrinkage
it also when you go to plane it um you
also see a reduction as well I'm going
to conclude my testimony at that um only
just you know saying that we don't think
this is necessary we think it would be
incredibly disruptive and unnecessary
for the industry we've done pretty well
trading our lumber domestically and
internationally with the nominal um oh
one last point was the way as drafted
this also
includes um Timber if you list it's it's
not just Lumber we're not just talking
about the rack at Home Depot um as
drafted it includes Timber and other
Forest Products and I wanted to before I
lose the M logs Timber and other wood
products and when I her purchase Timber
we think of that as standing Timber I go
in and cruise up an individual's wood
lot I give them an estimate of what's
out there obviously I don't measure
absolutely every single tree and say yes
to the to the you know to the decimal
point this is how many board feet this
is how many cords and this is how many
tons of these different products and so
that was another piece that some of our
actually Foresters and loggers had
raised is that if I'm buying in Timber
how would this affect me likewise we've
all many of you have probably purchased
cords of firewood 4et by 4 feet by 8T
well I can tell you I can stack a quart
of firewood 4 feet by 4 feet by
8T um my kids when they go to stack it
it's not 4 feet by 4 feet by 8 feet it's
usually off a little bit and it's just
how the pieces fit together again if I'm
selling firewood by the core Bo again
this kind
of affects that as well so with that
I'll conclude my testimony I'm happy to
you do we have regulations now on
cordwood in the 4x4 by8 is that in our
statute now yes we do the the New
Hampshire Department of Agriculture has
that they they and they do in fact
regulate that okay I knew that I knew
that but I just wanted you to say you
tested me
good repres ter so I I realize that the
bill is is focused at the at the at the
retail sales point and um and you know
what are what are the the actual
dimensions of a tu four at in in Home
Depot but I just want to be
clear um about what I thought I heard
you say so did you say that when a 2x4
is is MIL it's actually it's actually M
at 2x4 and then it shrinks
and so when I go to Home Depot it's
already shrunk yeah the the just want to
be clear yeah so so so when I the folks
that I talk
to that piece of lumber that you've
purchased at Home Depot has it was
originally 2 in by 4 in it goes through
a dry Kiln it gets
dried it shrinks and then it'll go
through a planer that Smooths it out so
it's nice and smooth and you have those
rounded corners and so at that point you
get these that's why you'll have these
nominal um and again you can buy from a
local local uh you know uh portable
sawmill and they can actually they'll
they'll saw whatever you want they'll
saw five quarter they'll saw four
quarter eight quarter for the question
so if I were to summarize what I think
I'm hearing you say uh a 2x4 is what it
was not what it is any longer at the
retail level it's what it was but it's
not what it is I guess that's a good way
of putting it great thank you
thanks it does say kill dry sometimes
they say kill dry and you got to assume
that putting it through the kilm is
going to make it drink a little bit Yeah
Yeah Lumber starts out about 50% water
okay
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking our questions um
to me this would you believe this this
sounds like like the original version of
shrink flation so we're familiar when we
go to the grocery store that the
packaging might be the same size but the
contents have shrunk magically right so
um I think this is uh I appreciate would
you believe I appreciate the uh the
representative bringing this to our
attention um this is sort of like a
maybe a little white lie that we've
gotten used to and uh we all kind of you
know have adjusted to it and uh it may
cause more disruption if we if we undo
it but I would believe
that okay we oh representative Cole has
a question what would be the cost
increase of lumber if something like
this was implemented oh my God it it
would be it would
be it would be significant if you think
about you know these Lumber Mills having
to maintain two sets of inventory
shipping
labeling um particularly if you're
shipping it putting in a container and
sending it over to China or you know
Europe having to to segregate it it it
would be it would be significant I I
can't give you a dollar amount but when
I talk to them they're in the business
of making you know making round logs
into square Lumber they said to create
yet a whole other
class of lumber and having to inventory
that and manage that inventory would be
significant
okay thank you very much thank you uh I
have one more card Curtis Barry uh the
Association good morning thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee uh I
am Curtis Barry here on behalf of the
New Hampshire retail Lumber Association
which is uh a group of about 48 local
independent building material suppliers
around the country that employ over
17,000 people most of the points I had
written down for the testimony have
already been covered including
representative ammon's comment earlier
about the width of the blade that's one
of the comments that the members made
that that blade width can vary from M to
Mill and therefore we'll adjust the size
of the of the board um I'd like to make
one comment expanding on representative
Terry's and representative K's um
questions the drying process isn't
something that happens all at once it
happens over time
time so you can get a piece of lumber or
a supply of lumber into the yard and if
it sits for a while it's going to dry
I'm wondering how
often the members of this Association
are going to have to send employees out
to measure each stick of lumber and then
change the labeling that I think from
our perspective is where the additional
cost will come in um and it would be
significant because labor is expensive
um the one point that hasn't been
covered I don't think is uh when
engineers and other folks draw up the
designs for a
building however they do their math
their specifications their formulas
whatever take into
account the capacity of a piece of
lumber 2x4 2x8 4 by8 what have
you it has a certain performance measure
and and limits and they take this into
account regardless of whether it's
actually 2x4 or 4 by8 it has a
performance standard that's really
what's important here the the lumber
will perform as the design specify so
this is
unnecessary well that's an interesting
point so you're saying that that um the
software program in which they use to um
do calculate the sizes to fit the plans
the software already has this
calculation and knows the wood is not
what not a 2x4 so uh that there would be
a nightmare at the designer's level to
try to hit handle sort out this problem
or there'll just be that specification
to say is we want the other side we want
we want special order 2x4s that are are
the old style or just or worst of all is
we don't buy it in New Hampshire we'll
go by it somewhere else perhaps yeah I
can't speak to what the ramifications on
the engineering end or on the software
end are uh I'm just suggesting that a
2x4 has to meet certain specifications
and if it's off a little bit it will
meet those specifications it will be
problematic if it doesn't yes okay any
other questions seeing none thank you
very
much okay
um uh all bills go to subcommittee so
you have a chance to rebut their their
points in the
subcommittee okay all right being 10:30
we're ready for the next bill uh
1395 relative to home heating oil and
get yes awesome thank you it's clerk's
office I need to take it to the clerk
that's where it came from okay and got
it from the clerk's office perfect thank
you
okay
yeah I'm just
G
morning good morning Mr representative
rung how are you today I'm very well how
about yourself just dead yeah I bet so
well thank you very much for allowing me
to be here to introduce to you house
spill 1395 and thank you commer
committee um about a year and a half ago
a constit oh and for the record my name
is Rosemary rung I represent Hillsboro
12 which is the town of marac about a
year and a half ago a constituent
brought to my attention problems he was
having with his propane company I was
unsure whether this was an isolated
incident or if it was widespread but I
started asking around town and asking on
social media if others had issues with
their propane company and word got
around and soon I was getting calls from
other towns Hollis Milford
Manchester and um they were also
experiencing incredible frustration with
their propane suppliers and the problems
were widespread it ranged from renting
uh charging rent on tanks that consumers
owned not responding to to requests to
remove a rented tank forcing online
agreements in order for a customer to
make a payment and not reimbursing a
pre- buby fee when the contract is
cancelled and there are many many more
um so last summer I contacted the senior
Assistant Attorney General uh Brandon
Gard from the consumer protection and
antitrust Bureau who confirmed that his
office does receive many complaints
about propane companies to get a
quantitative assessment of the extent of
problems Granite Staters are having I
requested copies of the complaints from
the past 3 years years and this is them
it's it's over 500 pages um I've I've
left this in um Miss Morris's office and
I I'll return it after the hearing so
feel free to go through them but it
outlines incredible frustration our
constituents are having with propane
dealers and I'm sure that not everybody
who has a problem knows enough to call
the Consumer Protection Bureau or wage a
complaint I'm sure for every one of
these there's probably 10 others so
based on these complaints you have HB
1395 in front of you and it seeks to
bring accountability by making the
following six changes to
statute one a contract must include any
pre- buby fees and ancillary charges
customers deserve to know what fees are
being
charged specific written or electronic
contact information for customers
wishing to discontinue service needs to
to be included um many of the
frustration is that people might call A
1 1800 number and it rings and Rings or
they're on hold forever and they just
don't have time to sit there and wait on
hold or go through this tree and then
ultimately get disconnected it should be
as easy to change suppliers as it is to
sign up companies make it very easy to
sign up for things but extremely
difficult to uh cancel that
Arrangement uh and also there's a
specific incident of a a a c a CL a
constituent of mine in maram who um got
a pre- buby agreement and but he ended
up being charged for the pre- buby and
it ended up the total cost was the same
as it would be if he didn't pre- buby
and so he cancelled but they wouldn't
give him the pre- buby fa feeback so I I
think those kind of arrangements need to
be
outlined and if the um the the um
the contact information um I would like
includeed on contracts for the New
Hampshire consumer protection and
antitrust Bureau I didn't even realize
being state representative and I'm in my
third term um the extent of the work
that this Bureau handles and the support
that it gives to Granite sters and I
think it behooves us to make sure that
we can promote that service to our
constituents as much as possible so
including that number on contract so if
people have a problem they can call blah
blah blah and the the um the fourth item
was pro-rated reimbursement for any
pre-bi fees I I already mentioned that
and also number five if the customer
notifies the dealer of any contract
discontinuance the dealer shall have 60
days from the date of customer
notification to remove their tank or
make every reasonable attempt to
transfer ownership to the consumer or to
another dealer
this is um a big problem and you'll see
it often in these consumer complaints is
a consumer may have entered a contract
with a propane company gets a great deal
goes on and realizes now the price is so
high or the ancillary charges have added
up they want to now go to another
company and they find that they either
have a real difficulty getting in touch
with their original supplier once they
do the supplier may take months and
months to come in get that tank and
other companies won't fill somebody
else's tank so those rental charges and
those ancillary charges still pile up um
for the consumer and as I said before we
should make it as easy as possible for a
consumer to exercise their choice in
going to a new supplier as it is for
companies to sign people up and finally
and I know this is going to sound like
common sense but no dealer May charge a
rental fee for a propane tank that they
don't own
or that is owned by another company that
does
happen so I've also included um well
just in my final remarks I just want to
say that these changes um to the
existing statute don't solve all the
problems but they are a start they will
put into law some minimum expectations
for companies delivering propane to
Granite Staters and I also want to be
clear about something to our
constituents this bill is not really
about propane it's not really about
Commerce it's about making sure their
family is warm in the winter we all know
what it was like last week Imagine your
propane tank is empty and your propane
dealer has reneged on a delivery or
you're getting you've been trying to
change customers to somebody that's more
affordable and you
can't our constituents want to have a
reliable estimate of how much it's
they're going to need to pay to provide
that warm home to their family amilies
and knowing that the state of New
Hampshire has their backs by placing
minimum expectations on companies doing
business with granite Staters um I've
also included in um my written testimony
that I handed out some of the things
I've heard from people this does not
this is not all that I've heard but the
first three comments came from members
of the Science and Tech Committee of the
house the chairman Vose made the first
comment a year ago um so I I I ask that
you consider this and I would be very
happy to um try to answer any of your
questions thank
you okay representative burrow yes
thanks for taking my question um can you
tell me if if a a similar bill has come
before the house um in the last few
years and if so what's different yeah
last year I actually had a bill I forget
the number of it representer Bros but it
was in response to some of the earlier
complaints I heard um I really wasn't if
it was widespread just antidotal so I
had a bill that was to establish a study
committee just to look at the extent of
this does it cross a lot of companies
and it passed a Science and Tech
committee and it passed the house but I
was so outnumbered by lobbyist and when
it went to the Senate that it didn't
make it through the senate committee um
but it that process and the attention
that bill brought made it clear that we
have to make some changes and that's why
I came I came this year with this spill
thank you thank you for the question
representa Terry thank you uh and thank
you for providing the uh the voluminous
uh evidence U that you have to uh the
committee uh but a confession I have not
yet reviewed all of that evidence and I
don't know whether it's categorized or
not hence my question and I would
appreciate uh your your best response um
with respect as you know bills are not
necessarily All or Nothing in terms of
how they come out of the committee Bill
may be amended uh I'd like to focus on
the provision with respect to the
parties that you're identifying who are
being charged rent for a tank that they
already
own um two two uh parts to this question
could you would you describe the
magnitude of this issue and number two
um why is it that that companies are
insisting on on being paid rent for
tanks that they don't own is this a
matter of confusion or or what is it
what and what what what is the
difficulty that the cons consumer and
the owner is experiencing in terms of
trying to resolve the issue is this
really a big problem so I'd appreciate
your response to those questions thanks
thank you very much I hope I I heard
them all thank you for the question I'll
try um I would say and just as it's just
from my own experience hearing from
constituents and I tried to create a
database base for this but it it's just
too much in fact I'll be bringing a bill
next year to um have the consumer Bureau
have an online database that so it's
very easy for them to sort through
complaints but um and it varies from
companies we have some excellent propane
supply companies in um in our state they
do a great job for their customers we
have one who is the major supplier who's
probably I would guess from what I've
heard 90% of the problem and um you know
we have laws
against murderers we have law but you
know not everybody's a murderer so but
we still have laws and so we could have
a really bad offender um but they're
getting away with it and many times
their justification for charging rent on
tanks they don't own is that a tank may
be underground and a customer may want
to go with them maybe there's very
limited suppliers in their area and they
have have a policy of not filling tanks
that they don't own so even though they
don't own it if the customer wants it
filled they charge rent and you will see
some some of the um quotes I have from
people that they may have been charged
rent for over 20 years the initial and I
believe I have his letter
included um there was the last letter
um this this uh miramac resident had
built a house had it uh or yeah he had
it built I mean some people have bought
a house that has a underground propane
tank they've owned it it's been part of
the sales and purchase agreement but and
and the company May Supply propane for I
think this is like 10 or 20 years and
then all of a sudden start charging
rent
and you know it it's it's more
widespread than you think I think
there's other people here that can
probably comment more about
that okay representative Emon thank you
Mr chair thank thank you for presenting
this testimony um I I'm kind of zeroing
in on the pre- buby aspect um so the
existing law says that the contract uh
shall require dealers to reimburse
customers at the contract price for any
undelivered pre-purchased fuel so that's
existing law and then you're adding and
any pro-rated pre-bi fees and then later
in that same paragraph it says unless
they agree to different terms so uh a
customer can sign a contract that has
completely different terms than what
what is existing law or what you're
adding but could you explain the preby
uh fees what what how's that different
from the the pre purchased fuel oh okay
um thank you very much representative
for the question what and that came from
a constit another a different
constituent of mine but he wanted to
take advantage of the pre-bi price for
propane but they charged him to take
advantage of that so they charged him a
pre buy fee to get the propane at a
pre-bi price and he realized when he
added up this he just saw his bill pre-
buby fee and it was because it was a
charge that they were waging on on his
account because he was taking advantage
of the pre-bi program and when he
cancelled he wanted to get a portion of
that pre- buby back and they denied him
so further question me inquire thank you
um so just focusing on the preby it's my
understanding that uh because um there
there's a time value of money right so
you you you take a risk as a consumer
that you're getting a good price and and
you're kind of splitting that risk with
uh the supplier because the price of
fuel could go up or it could go down and
if we're allowing people to kind of
renag on that that risk taking let's say
the price goes way down and they want to
get it sort of like puts the risk all on
the supplier and uh would you see it
that way I mean I thank you for the
question I agree that you know being
reimburse for a pre- buby of fuel
doesn't make much sense because it is a
risk but it's the pre- buby fee it's
this a cons customer has to pay to even
participate in the pre- buby and that's
a set fee so I don't see where there
would be um any risk it's more of just
an assess M to participate like a
participation fee in this preby and it's
not the pre- buby fee and and I'm sure
people that are here can can give you a
better answer but my thoughts are that
the preby fee is just a fee to
participate it's not based on any uh
level of risk of getting that fuel at a
lower price do you know what the pre-
see this customer sent me their
agreement with a maragas two pages I
don't know if I can even read
it there's a safety assurance check fee
leak check fee meter fee paper invoice
fee that's
$299 tank pickup fee that's 200
reconnect charge return check fee
service dispatch charge emergency
delivery fee will call convenience fee
minimum delivery fee site survey fee
underground T tank removal late fees
credit card surcharge equipment rent I
assume this but this is all all the
other stuff so the the question I would
have is that um when you're doing a pre-
buby you're writing the check for the
full amount
mhm up front yep so at that time you're
writing the check they should that in
that invoice they're sending to you
they're telling you what the price of
the gas is and then they should also be
putting in that there's a fee to do this
pre- buby right should it should be
written into that so he did pay it up
front even right out of the
get-go you know I assume so I'm gonna
assume you're correct Mr chair okay but
my concern is when they're advertising
and I do have some of the Flyers because
they send it to me and I I don't have
propane
um
um if you I'll have to go I'll pass this
around but I don't believe that they
list the pre-bi fee on
here free installation for lease tanks
are they listing the price of the fuel
um extra 20% off per gallon with code
summer
ff20 um so there's no pricing or any
dollar amounts in this FL anyways no
because that's the problem with the
pre-u I mean just so you know
historically that uh there was a period
of time where we were losing Oil Dealers
you know I think Fuller I think was the
big one but we were losing Oil Dealers
right and left and they all blamed the
preby as the reason they lost their
shirt because they under they
underpriced the preby
so not withstanding that so I that's you
know you know my interest will
definitely be what is the contractional
arrangement what is the consumer really
being told or no before they get into
the deal um certainly I can imagine they
don't have an exit strategy right they
don't say this it's just open-ended and
that's part of the problem is that
consumer signs this thing and and might
be happy for several years and then
after some point in time when someone
says well I'm getting it you know with
this price and he so oh my God I'm
paying so much more why well because I
signed up with this contract that never
had an exit strategy so I I think I
think that's worth looking at one thing
and I and I'm just scanning this bill
but one thing I see in here uh is like I
think you're actually want to put pre-bi
out of business is um a surity bond made
payable to attorney general the amount
not less than 50% of the total amount of
funds paid to the dealer by consumers or
100% um what line do you see that on is
it this is I guess is this I think it's
existing that's already in so the only
thing we your bill is the Bol pH stuff
right okay so so they already have the
obligation okay yeah and and Mr I have
nothing against preby I you know if I
was a company and I want to assume that
risk of a price increase for getting my
my propane at wholesale I totally agree
with that but they're passing that risk
on to the consumer with that pre- buby
fee so um essentially the consumer is
not benefiting from and the company is
is hedging their beted actually with the
pre- buby
fee right but it but again if the
consumer writes that check and pays them
they they kind of own that pre-bi fee
don't you don't they no I I agree I
think we need to make sure that that's
very clear to the customer that okay
we're going to offer you this propane at
a discounted price at a pre-bi price but
you have to pay for that opportunity to
get it at this price and you know you
have to pay a set amount of fee for
it
spear thank you just so I understand
this in reading this we're not forcing
anybody to do anything different than
what they were doing but just to let the
customer know what it is they're doing
am I reading that right that we're just
we're not changing how anything operates
like getting rid of preby fees or
anything like that we're just it looks
like we're just telling them you've got
to let the customer know what's going on
am am I right about that well there
would be some difference with like the
pre-bi fee customers would I mean
companies would have to refund a a
certain amount a pro-rated amount if
cancelled so yeah okay so the obviously
I wasn't paying attention that this is
this is stuff we have had a lot of this
stuff is already here in this bill so um
but that's for for discussion purposes
um that in terms of looking at just
these little narrow sections of the law
that you want to add here the only
question I would have is if there
contract that that if that the exit
strategy is in the contract or that that
you know if something is written you
know this thing shall have 60 days from
the date of
notification I just want to make sure
that if they've already have that in the
contract about how quickly they were
supposed to remove something we don't
that the statute should not you know
change what was in the contract whatever
whatever someone's contract is is their
contract and that I'm going back to
someone who wrote a contract 20 years
ago and and how do they get out of it
then then we you know you need to write
something because I'm assuming in that
contract there was no exit strategy
there was no expiration to it whereas if
I would hope that nowadays more
contracts would be but we'll find out
okay repr post thank you very much Mr
Taran thank you for this bill um I did
have a a pre-bi several years and that's
a contract that you enter into and it
there is it's seasonal it's a seasonal
one so and if it's colder you use more
early you might not have as much I I I
ran into that I found that was a problem
and I never did a pre- buby again but I
would say there are some years where
it's great and some years where it's not
and I believe that's a contract and it
ends so um I I can't see really the need
for um if you're going to sign a
contract that contract stays in
place and he should have known what he
paid for it right they give you all the
information so I wonder if um he didn't
look at his document about his pre- bite
price so I I would be interested to know
if that was the issue to because they
give you the
prices no I I totally agree with you I
have nothing against pre-bi programs I
think my husband and I have probably
participated some in the past my issue
is I think companies need to be more
upfront if they're going to charge you
to participate in that um do you have to
pay an additional fee to be in that
pre-bi
program we did it was just an upfront
fee and it wasn't very big it was just
um part of the contract and they did
they did write it out it was Eastern
Propane so we had no problem we still
use them but we use them in a different
capacity now okay thank you but thank
you I I would be be interested to know
if he if he knew the number up
front he called me then he sent me this
contract which I really can barely read
um but he was very upset because the fee
when he learned of the fee just to
participate in the program it wiped out
any savings the price he would have paid
for propane that day was equal to the
pre- buby price plus this fee that was
being added on so he really wasn't
enjoying a pre-bi price because this
added fee was negating the savings he
would have had from it representative
Sullivan just on I mean actually some of
the things are covering here make up
pretty good but I'm I'm also concerned
with the pre- buby uh discussion so like
even in the example you were just
talking about where the guy had this pre
pre-bi fee and when you looked at the
fee it looked like the the the
difference adding that to the cheaper
price for the pre-bi fee or the pre-
buby price was deating the the savings
that he would have got if he just bought
in the spot Market but that's in that
situation like if if the spot Market had
let's just make a crazy example it
doubled in price surely the fee plus the
price he agreed on would have been still
cheaper and he probably would have been
happy with the deal it sounds to me like
he just might not have been happy with
it and that that's how I'm interpreting
what you're saying like if the mar and I
think that's sort of what representative
post was saying that is if if the price
Market moves in an unfavorable way then
the pre- buy is not a good deal but if
it moves in a very favorable way you
know prices double over the winter for
some strange reason you you've locked in
a great price it makes sense to me that
there would be a Fe to participating in
that program because now that's some of
the that's the benefit you're paying to
participate in that so I'm C I mean I'm
fine with all the disclosures and the
extent that there is a lack of
disclosure of what these fees be may be
and it sounds like we're not entirely
clear at this moment whether or not that
was the problem or if he just was
unhappy with the price that he was
getting it wasn't as cheap as he thought
it was going to be with the fee um those
are two different two different things
so I'm not I'm not entirely sure from
this discussion what we're addressing
and I read I've read through the bill
it's also not clear to me it's it sounds
to me that this is being motivated by
somebody who's unhappy with the price
plus the fee um or was he unhappy that
it was somehow not
disclosed in the point when he signed
the contract if that's the case and that
is a problem I agree but I want I'm
trying to get to what problem is okay no
my understanding and thank you for the
question my understanding from my
conversation with him is that he was
unaware that he was going to have
in in his mind a very large fee to pay
because when he entered into the
agreement he realized that the pre- buby
price and the fee that he was going to
have to pay to participate was equal to
what he would be getting anyway if he
was just buying without the prepay and
when he um canceled the contract he was
upset that they didn't um refund him a
um part of the fee you know the
pro-rated part of the fee that he lost
all of that fee for the term of the
preby contract see the problem you keep
saying he didn't know it was going
forward okay part of the pre-bi is you
have no idea what the price of propane
is going to be going forward okay so he
absolutely knew how much he paid for a
fee because he wrote the check already
he already bought the propane with the
fee upfront so you keep saying is he
didn't
know that it was going to be that much
but that's part of the gamble that you
make that you don't know what at the end
of the day what you know what the price
of PR pain is going to be and so
therefore you have to when you pay that
fee up front to make that deal right
that he wrote that check up front with
that fee he was making a bet that that
check was going to be less if
then what it would been if he had not
signed the prei may I have a followup Mr
chair follow-up ch um
so if what you're telling me is or and
you're not saying this but let's say
that this gentleman has the contract he
could show it to you or us this
committee whatever that this fee was
somehow not disclosed that's absolutely
a problem and i' would be interested to
know that but my guess is my hunch is
that's probably not the case um and he
just sounds like he might be unhappy
that the market didn't move to help help
him or make it seem like it was a a good
bet that he made he made a bet that
wasn't worked out so um I'm I would be
interested to learn though that if
somehow this was not disclosed then that
is a problem and we should address it
but I it from this discussion it doesn't
seem like we know that so that's just
sort of my take yeah he he didn't when
when he called me he had just signed up
for it and when he did the calculation
it wasn't like he even knew that the
price was going to change whether it
went up or down he was just like oh my
gosh this pre- buy fee is so high um and
this is what I'm paying like I said I'm
totally fine with preby but I I really
wonder in that spec and that's one of a
million complaints is that he did not
have a good understanding of these
ancillary costs that he was going to
have to pay Beyond participating in the
program okay well that's going to be
hard to leg SL but okay all right
pelli thank you um Mr chairman and thank
you for the concern but I don't I don't
want to legislate based on one anecdote
but you do have several inches there of
complaints so if I were to look through
all of those complaints you mentioned
it's 90% of them are from one
company is that true I'm estimating um
yes and what did and I would be able to
find find out what that I don't want you
when you when you open it up you'll see
it okay so I will be able to determine
what that company was from he's actually
mentioned the name already so absolutely
ass I'm assuming it begins with an A and
it ends with a s know and I would like
to know what is it that the um consumer
protection and he's about to testify so
as soon as we're all done with our
questions we'll hear from the consumer
protection they did to remediate this
yes okay and um it just seems like just
to make a fine point these are more
disclosures as opposed to the uh in
addition to the rental fee so what what
the bill really drives is more
disclosure right at the time of signing
up and making sure that it's very clear
but what I'm not sure I think on the
back page it does say it bans the fee
okay but I want to make sure like as you
said that we're not um in in conf
conflict with whatever other laws exists
or what Contra the contract may say I
just want to make sure that we
understand right I
mean thank you for the question uh yeah
and most of it's one company I mean for
Mo I would say for most small to medium
propane companies that operate in New
Hampshire this isn't going to change
anything for them they're already
operating very responsibly but there's
zero guard rails on this big company who
continually and and this is just from
three years they've been in operation in
the state longer there's just no guard
rails on them and when they take
advantage of consumers they're taking
advantage of someone's ability to
provide a warm home for their family
it's it's the the frustration is just
incredible um and I I would ask all of
you go back to your districts and ask
around ask people what their experience
has been with their propane
company yeah we have a HomeTown one so
we all love ours okay representative
Herbert um maybe you don't know this or
the my question is oftentimes I mean the
Commodities are very
volatile and uh so they they go up and
down more than secur other Securities
but is there an insurance policy that
the supplier can take um and and and and
res and the risk goes up to some
investor somewhere else I'm just curious
because I mean that is often times a a
technique that are that is used in order
to push off the risk of a of a seller of
some product and they buy some insurance
and it's aggregated into a you know U
like mortgages you know what I mean is
there anything like that for these guys
um I don't thank you for the question
represent I don't know but I would think
if if I owned a propane company and I
wanted to increase business by offering
a pre-bi program I'm assuming risk that
I'm going to have to pay more but I can
definitely hedge that by charging a
really high pre uh pre- buby
participation
fee so that could almost be looked at as
an
insurance well again a preby is
something that you choose to do later
after youve already have a relationship
with a propane company right so okay I
think we should hear my question was is
there a secondary Market that insure
right now at right now the problem is
going back to the original issue of
propane is that a lot of these propane
companies will actually give you the
tank for
free on the assumption that you are just
going to buy them so this is like a cell
phone right Verizon gives you the phone
for free but you have to sign up for a
to your contract and don't try to get
out of it okay thank you very much thank
you very
much
book we do have our consumer protection
protection
morning
good
morning thank you Mr chairperson members
of the committee uh as some of you may
know my name is Brandon Gad I am a
senior Assistant Attorney General chief
of the consumer protection and anti
trust Bureau at the New Hampshire
Department of Justice um the Department
of Justice is not taking a formal
position on this bill this morning but I
I would like to share that we are very
close to supporting it um there are a
couple of areas where it could be
improved and I think that is the only
only thing that is keeping us from
supporting it at this time but if a few
minor moderations were modifications
were made I think there's a very high
likelihood that the Attorney General
would support this bill because as the
representative just testified to U some
of the issues that are addressed in here
are major problems in this state and are
a frequent source of consumer complaints
to the Department of
Justice and so I I think that you know
after witnessing the discussion that
just took place the way I could be most
helpful
is to walk through this bill and talk
about the different things that it does
from my understanding the actual impact
that it would have because I think there
is a bit of misunderstanding um and then
also talk about what we see in the
Consumer Protection Bureau in terms of
the extent of each of these changes and
the problems that they would purportedly
fix so if you start at the beginning you
know the the changes that are made under
you know paragraph 1 A and B as I
understand it this is simply just a
matter of disclosure um requires
disclosure of any fees that are going to
be charged regardless of their pre-bi
fees ancillary charges or fees for
anything else it simply requires fees to
be disclosed in a reasonable manner in a
in a contract for the purchase um of
fuel regardless of whether it is a
pre-bi contract or any other contract
any contract has to disclose all fees so
you know from the attorney general's
perspective that's a good thing
consumers are signing up for things they
should know what the fees are and make
informed decisions about whether or not
they want to enter into that contract
um what the other thing that this does
is require that every contract contain
information contact information to the
New Hampshire Department of Justice
consumer protection hotline so this is
one of the areas where I think this
could be improved um I think including
and the Attorney General believes that
including contact information for the
consumer protection hotline is a good
thing and that the sooner that consumers
have issues with home heating fuel and
know who to call the better for the
reasons that we're just testifying to we
live in a state where you know a large
portion of the Year people need to be
able to heat their homes and if they
can't or if they're having issues
resolving a problem that's preventing
them from heating their home they should
there should be a very clear who do I
contact in order to address this so I
think adding contact information for our
Bureau to the contract is a good thing
but the way this is worded it simply
says that they have to have the contact
information for the Department of
Justice consumer protection hotline uh
to make this truly effective and
enforcable I think that if the the
legislature is considering you know
moving this bill forward they should
think carefully about a exact verbatim
language that should be included in
every single contract something along
the line of lines of if you have any
issues receiving a fuel delivery or any
issues with the provisions of this
contract you can contact the Consumer
Protection Bureau hotline at this number
and the reason I say that is because
right now all that's required is contact
information so a phone number could be
buried in the bottom without any
explanation uh without any guidance as
to what they can contact us for um and I
don't know that that would make a
meaningful difference but if you if you
want to make this enforcable and
worthwhile I think you have to very
clearly articulate verbatim What
language needs to be in there and it
should there should be some sort of
requirement that it's you know certain
size of font possibly boldface lettering
something like that so it can't simply
be hidden at the bottom of you know
several pages of you know microscopic
font that consumers can't
see so moving on to you know what else
this bill would do um I think if you
look to so I I'd like to talk about
pre-bi because I think pre-bi was the
issue that you know most of the members
of this committee had concerns about and
was the majority of the discussion that
took place so you know as you pointed
out there already is you know there is
there is already a law in place that
requires you know there are certain
requir ments if you fail to deliver on a
prepaid contract for heating fuel and
that is a very narrow category of you
know contract where the consumer pays
upfront at the beginning of the season
for a quantity of fuel and then it's to
be delivered throughout the season at
the price that they already paid um so
as I understand what this would do by
adding and any pre-bi fees to the
requirement that consumers are
reimbursed for any undelivered pre
purchased fuel I don't in I don't
interpret this as being a situation even
though it was the focus of the one
complaint that was referenced um all
this does is if the company fails to
deliver the fuel that was pre-bought the
consumer is not only entitled to you
know the m a pro-rated version of what
they paid for the fuel but also a
pro-rated version of the pre-bi fee that
they paid so I think it's consistent
with the law that we already have all it
is is doing is wrapping in any pre-bi
fee into what the customer is entitled
to if the company fails to deliver the
fuel that the consumer pre paid for at
the beginning of the Season which I also
think is you know a very strong consumer
protection policy that could potentially
do a lot of good if companies are
failing to deliver the fuel that
customers have already prepaid for the
question of whether a customer knows
about a pre-bi fee at the time they
entered in or didn't read the contract
carefully enough then tries to get out
of the contract because of the pre- buby
fee that's not an issue that this would
cover this doesn't help people get out
of their contracts all it does is
creates a requirement where if a
consumer prepays for fuel and the
company fails to deliver that fuel
there's a remedy for the customer to get
their money back so the key word there
is the undelivered that's right okay so
good it's good language just because
it's in the undelivered that's right
okay great and in terms of you know the
prevalence of pre- buby contract issues
those are not as common I think when
companies do pre you know we do receive
complaints somewhat consistently
consumers often don't know whether
they've actually entered into a pre-
buby or are in more of a you know a lot
of these companies will sign them up for
automatic delivery where they don't pay
for it in advance but they automatically
deliver the fuel without the customers
needing to contact them and then they'll
charge them for it after it's delivered
there's a lot of confusion I think with
consumers in terms of whether that is
pre- buby or not um so a lot we get a
lot of pre- Buy complaints that aren't
actually pre- Buy complaints but with
this language and the language that
already exists for pre-b I think that
consumers are and will be better
protected if this language is added but
I don't think that is the key problem
that this bill is intended to address
the key problem and the overwhelming
majority of the complaints that the
Consumer Protection Bureau receives
about propan companies in particular are
issues with the tank because the tank is
the key to being able to receive propane
into your home and if you have an
existing tank and the company refuses to
remove it another company is not going
to touch another company's tank for
liability reasons so having a mechanism
for consumers to cancel a contract where
they have a rented tank on their
property and have it promptly removed so
that they could switch companies and
move to a diff whether it's a better
price or you know better service or
whatever it is I think that's a really
strong protection that our statutes are
currently lacking and it is a huge
source of frustration for consumers in
this state people buy homes where
there's an existing tank owned by a
company that they've never contracted
with and they want to sign up with a
different company and they can't get
that tank removed quickly sometimes it
takes six months sometimes it takes a
year um consumers want to switch
companies because they're unsatisfied
with the price or the new fees that
they're being charged or the customer
service that they're getting or not
getting and they try to cancel their
contract and the response that they get
is we'll get it when we can get it but
we're busy so you know we'll get it when
we can get it this would require within
60 days that they have to remove that
tank I think that is a a reasonable
measure that would make a huge
difference in addressing the issue of
consumers being able to effectively
choose between competing companies and
have a removed promptly so that they can
make a switch if they are choosing to do
so um the only this language you know is
another area where I do think though it
could be improved a little bit um it has
an alternative to the the 60 days for
the the removal of the tank whereby they
have to make reasonable efforts to
either transfer ownership um to the
consumer or to another dealer and my
only issue there is with the reasonable
attempt language Concepts like
reasonable attempts are very very
difficult for the Attorney General's
office to enforce you know what what's
reasonable based on you know how many
other customers they have to deal with
how many you know folks people have you
know working at the company at the time
whether there is any interest in another
company buying it or whether the
consumer or the company are being
unreasonable about negotiations for the
purchase price it's just unclear as to
what a reasonable attempt would be and
that might lead to some difficulties in
enforcement but you know I I've spoken
to the representative about this I think
that you know if the legislature were to
decide to move forward with this you
know the the way to make this more
enforcable is to put the burden on the
consumer who is looking to move on from
the company to tell them exactly what
they want you know consumer either has
to tell them I want to have the tank
removed or I want the tank transferred
to another company or I want to purchase
the tank and then they have a set amount
of time to accomplish that goal if you
have that list and it takes the customer
has the initial burden of saying um
here's what I want to do I'm switching
providers then the company has to do it
if they can within a set period of time
um that would make this more enforcable
and I think that would address a lot of
the complaints that we see with issues
about you know propane tanks and how
long it takes companies to remove
them so question so so you you want to
change the make every reasonable ATT to
just simply say from the date of
notification remove their
tank or transfer ownership to consumer
in another days within the 60-day window
you know I I I'm not going toine on the
specific window that's appropriate but
if it were 60 days I think that what
would make this enforceable from the
attorney general's perspective is if the
customer notifies the company hey I want
to I want to buy this tank they have 60
days to facilitate that or remove the
tank
if the customer wants to transfer
ownership to another company they say
hey I'm going from company a to Company
B okay and Company B has expressed an
interest in buying this tank so they can
service this tank then company a has 60
days to either transfer ownership or
remove the tank right so basically I'm
scratching out make every reasonable
attempt to or transfer ownership to the
consumer or another dealer that's right
and we can negotiate the 60 days and if
that might be a problem but okay so okay
so that's we're I don't I don't claim to
be an expert on what an appropriate time
period is but whatever the time period
is it needs to be one that a is
reasonable but also one that can
facilitate meaningfully a consumer
switching providers if they want to in
the middle of a you know a winter season
where they can't afford to be when every
time it ever came to a buried tank is
and for me and i' I've dealt with this a
couple times it's either I either either
I just buy the tank outright or I've
actually had to buy a tank to the guy
who was leaving I had to buy their tank
and then they delivered it to the other
guy to the guy who was losing his tank
but in either case uh when it's buried
it's problematic but so usually but just
to say is that that that transfer has to
happen within 60 days okay R Terry thank
you uh so I'm I'm curious um what is the
legal
basis for a
company charging a rental fee for a tank
that it does not
own all right and because that's what we
heard and then secondly I don't could
you could you address how it is what's
the legal basis for
tying
the the the fee for being in a preby
arrangement
with the pre- buby price contract such
that for and let me
illustrate it's oil and not propane but
it's it's it's the same it's just apples
different kinds of apples here um at the
end of a pre- bubye I used less fuel
than I contracted for and the companies
told me we'll either give you the
difference back or we'll credit to next
year well I thought you know that that
was very appropriate that was very nice
appreciated that however with respect to
the fee why should I have expected that
I would receive a pro rated refund on
the fee that I had paid just to be able
to enter into the program with other
people so two questions thank you you're
welcome uh answer your first question
what legal basis is there for a company
to charge a tank rental fee for a fee
they don't own uh you would have to ask
the company because I can't think of one
I mean that is that is not a common
source of complaint I you know the
representative represented she's
reviewed all of these more recently than
I have you know three years worth of
complaints I don't recall that specific
complaint I'm not willing to say it
doesn't exist I assume it does since she
referenced it but I can't imagine what
legal basis there would be but that
would be a question dealt we may have we
may have I just can't recall I mean it's
three years worth of complaints she's
referencing no no I'm only resp I'm only
I'm only referencing one particular
complaint and as far as you know your
department has not dealt with the
complaint of an that he doesn't know you
don't know I don't remember it off the
top of my head I look at all the
complaints all the complaints not just
the propane complaints not just the
recent complaint he gets a lot of
complaints yeah I've been I've been bu
for four and a half years and I've
looked at every single complaint other
than when I've been on vacation so how
about the pre how about the pre- buby
isn't a pre-bi a onetime transaction fee
for doing the doing the pre- buby
shouldn't you that not necessarily be
why should that beated refunded if the
company fails to deliver the fuel no
well that's what it says
undelivered the undelivered portion or
the entire Su it it it says here okay to
that so your arguing is well yeah it was
undelivered because he told me they
didn't have to deliver so much propane I
didn't need it right I didn't need all
that propane so yeah I was undelivered
because they the tank couldn't take it
he didn't use it they couldn't use it so
so if that was so the the undelivered so
maybe it's really the undelivered is
because they failed to deliver rather
than the word undeliver that is how I've
always interpreted that statute it's a
protection against a consumer paying a
large you know purchase price Upfront
for something that they're going to
expect to get over time and then the
company fails to up hold their end so we
changed undelivered to unfiled to
deliver would that because that that
would mean that the the preby the prated
preby I don't think there's a difference
well failed to Del failed to deliver is
that they Del definitely delivered all
the propane you
needed they got you what you needed it
just happened that that winter was very
mild yes and so therefore you didn't
need as much as you pre- buby right the
isn't then at that time the pro the pre
the pre- buby was just a transaction fee
for doing the preby and shouldn't
actually be pro-rated at that point
right so the only way that I I see what
the argument that you're making my point
is that simply saying fail to deliver
and changing it from undelivered to fail
to deliver doesn't make that distinction
if you want to make that distinction you
can put a definition in the section that
defines What fail to deliver means or
what unel in in this sentence and and if
F feel in any prr pre- buby fees if the
uh UND delivered was due
to the fact uh uh we try to the
semantics to clear that that that they
shouldn't have to pay the pr pro-rated
fee if uh it was because they didn't
need the gas or some you'd have to put a
definition in there to specify this mean
undelivered or failed to deliver means
this but doesn't mean this gotcha
okay all right representative
axon so can I understand from the your
testimony in your reading of this bill
which sounds like it's different from my
reading of this bill that it would not
be your understanding that this bill
seeks to prate back a flat transaction
fee based there's a when you sign a pre-
buby contract I'm it says I'm going to
buy 2,000 gallons of gas at $189 a a
gallon M and there's a contract fee for
buying this option of
$250 and so your testimony is that you
do not believe this bill requires that
that $250 transaction be be prated back
if I only use 1,800 gallons do I
understand you correctly or
not you do but there's a clarification
that needs to be made so this my
understanding of this legislation the
one that's enacted and the Amendments
that are seeking to be made here were
enacted in direct response to a
situation where a company does pre- buys
at the beginning of the season and then
they go out of business so they can't
deliver the fuel that the customer has
already purchased that's right that's
what that's what the original statute
was so if that happens and you pay a
pre-bi fee at the beginning I think it's
consistent with this statute that the
customer should be entitled to that
pre-bi fee PR rated back to them because
the company's gone and can't deliver
what the person paid for that's very
different from a situation where like
we're talking about here today the non
delivery is not based on the company
just doesn't do it there's a Justified
reason for it that's something different
and perhaps that's a clarification that
needs to be made or should be made in
the statute so that everybody's really
clear as to what types of situations
these apply to but the Attorney General
consumer protection bureau's
interpretation of this statute has
always been this applies in situations
where customers prepay at the beginning
of the season for something that the
company then fail to deliver because
they can't they either don't or they
can't because they've gone out of
business or they run out of oil or they
you other reasons that are squarely the
fault of the company and no fault of the
consumer but clearly it you know it was
never designed to be a situation where
you know if the if they the tank
couldn't take any more oil then you want
to penalize the company for that reason
that's my understanding I mean that's
why the the statute was enacted is my
understanding because that has happened
a couple of times in New Hampshire um
and that's how I've always interpreted
it through an enforcement lens
representative meu and then
representative Burrows and then
representative
post thank you Mr chairman thanks for
providing the enlightening testimony um
to put it in context the three years of
complaints is this the most common
complaint that your agency deals with at
least in the in the winter or in this
subject matter and and secondly can you
opine a little bit on the right way to
provide remedy if a dealer doesn't
remove it in 60 days for instance if
they just ghost you don't respond you're
in you know call center never Neverland
or whatever and you need to process real
estate transactions or whatever it is
for whatever reason the consumer just
has it
removed should they be then able to
charge that potentially large expense to
the company for not having complied with
the proposed statute like comment a
little bit on how that how we should
remedy that in those what if situations
I think I understand so or or sorry one
last thing like what if they just say
sure you can buy it it's cost you a
million dollars or we'll remove it and
sure then they have to remove it for
that well not necessarily as I mean they
could say sure we'll remove it in 60
days if you pay us to remove it or
whatever but anyways just like your
opinion on that first question was is
this the most common complaint that we
receive it is one of the most common I I
have not I don't I'd be surprised if it
was the most common um you know candidly
the most common complaints that we seem
to receive consistently involve
contractors and used car sales um I
think this very likely may be three or
four if I were to guess um we also see
receive a huge volume of complaints
against cable and internet providers um
so those those four would you know those
that would be my top four if you ask me
I don't know that I I could definitely
order them for you here today but you
know your your question about I think
your question is yeah how would this
work in terms of a remedy so what this
would do is it would make failure to
comply with any provision of this
statute and unfair deceptive actor
practice under
358a um and so if the consumer
contacted a company and said I'd like to
switch providers please remove the tank
60 days passed they didn't do it
consumer had to hire somebody else to
remove the tank so they expended a lot
of money one of the remedies we can get
if we bring an enforcement action under
the consumer protection act is
restitution for the consumer so that's
how it would work it also would give uh
there's a private right of action under
the consumer protection act so even if
we didn't take that action consumer
would be empowered to go to court and
seek restitution um or damages based on
you know the money that they had to
expend in getting the tank
threefold three times as much triple
Dames triple damages so only it's
purpose yeah sue sue them get the state
to bring in enforce enforcement action
and you know okay I that's not triple
damage no that that's you get they get
restitution at that point okay um oh we
got I'm representative adman had
recognized me when you Ste down okay
okay um quick question for the
complaints related to propane is it is
it one company that gets most of them or
is they across the board it is one
company that gets most like
percentagewise I'm not asking the name
yet I mean I would just be spitballing
but I would guess it's at least 75%
thank
you okay thank you very much thank you I
hope you all have your mic's off now
right I will I can assure you they're
not here today okay Bob Scully who
represents the uh
propane dealers in general what is this
I can't even read your writing
energy the energy marketers Association
Mark looks like mothers oh
sorry thank you Mr chairman for the
record my name is Bob Scully I represent
the energy marketers Association New
Hampshire which is our your retail Oil
Dealers um and I appear in opposition to
House Bill 1395
um some of the discussion on preby goes
back to 20 years ago where Jim buffetti
was here instead of Brandon and the
common denominator was your chairman and
myself um when it was issues with a
dealer that um collected money and did
not deliver was no longer in business
today so um we have some experience here
what I do want to bring to your
attention uh represent run referred to
last year she put a study bill in um and
we opposed that study bill and I want to
tell you why the same the same arguments
um are with us today we've talked about
one company one dealer it's a bad apple
it's the largest dealer in the state of
New Hampshire okay it's a mergas so we
don't have to guess that's who it is um
also testify testimony earli today
that's 90% of the complaints at the AG's
office okay um we were promised those
listed complaints that you all have
there but we've never received a copy so
we haven't been able to vet them take a
look at them to able to comment on them
today uh but there are 50 propane
dealers in the state of New Hampshire um
and I believe they're reputable um I
believe they work hard for their
customers I believe they exchange tanks
with one another there's two dealers
here after me so I'm going to be brief I
can explain how that works and I would
just urge great caution as we oppose
this that we don't put something in
place that that makes it difficult for
dealers to work to take care of their
customers
um I will also tell you in the in the
trade magazines that we have that the
company that's causing all this problem
um for you're here for House Bill 1395
today their residential business in the
state of New Hampshire is for sale so it
is our hope that a reputable company
will purchase them and take care of
their customers the way that we believe
the other 49 in the state
do and um so I would not like to see 49
customers pay the price for a bad apple
um if you can figure a way to get them
go for it but um they are also not a
member of the energy marketers
Association so I feel free to speak so
um there are
um sections in this bill and and
exchanging tanks if for some reason this
bill goes forward I would kindly ask you
to ask the deal is behind me um 60 days
is certainly not a viable option in
December January February feary and
March um but they know how to do this um
and I would just ask you to please
listen to them and also the woman Leslie
Anderson was behind me represents the
propane gas Association of New England
um so she can answer a question
specifically to that but my concern is
we're here today because we had one very
bad company um that we admitted right up
front um and I would ask you to take
that in consideration when you when you
make your decision thank you Mr chairman
okay perfect all right Rob uh
Partners okay anybody here have simple
Energy Partners their propane guess we
don't have anybody from the I have some
applications with me we'll take care of
that before I go um especially for
representative uh wrong it's it's tragic
that I'm not operating in her Market
because we wouldn't be here today if
that were the case I can assure you uh
I'm a little bit disappointed I had a
lot of stuff prepared and that is sure
hope yeah do all that often the case uh
but just by listening uh I rewrote a lot
of what I want to share with you today
but at a respect for everyone's time I
do want to give you a little bit of
background for the purpose of providing
some perspective on my level of
expertise here um I I'm a 32ye veteran
of the petroleum marketing industry uh
half of my career was spent uh in the
state of Maine um operating u a huge
book of business for Dead River Company
and then also with Irving Oil as well I
work in their refining group um this is
the business that I love it's the
business I've been in my entire adult
life and in 2006 I started my own um Oil
and Propane company in West Lebanon New
Hampshire uh that company is called
Simple energy and there is no secret
behind why I named my company simple
energy I identified a long time ago that
this industry is anything but simple and
strategically if we can make these
transactions simple for our customers we
we win um and so to that end I want to
offer a little bit more uh perspective
on where my experience uh comes from uh
I I was
uh I was convinced to take a role in our
state trade Association uh back in I
think somewhere around 2010 but in 2014
uh that participation Advanced me to the
role of chairman of the what was then
the oil heat Council of New Hampshire um
today that's known as the energy
marketers Association of New Hampshire
on my sixth day January 6th of 2014 of a
volunteer position that I really didn't
want I got a phone call from Bob Scully
at 9:00 at night at home and he said Rob
I just got off the phone with the
governor and I said why on Earth would
you be calling me and he said I need you
to tell me everything you know about
Fred Fuller and I said I I'll tell you
what our industry has been jumping up
and down and yelling and screaming at
every regulatory Authority that will
listen to us for a very long time that
he is destined to fail he will run out
of luck this is something that we've
predicted for a very long time and he's
not alone there were two companies that
that uh that came before Fred that that
uh by by the way uh chairman hun I don't
want to uh correct you you seem like a
smart guy but those companies didn't
fail because of the preby program those
companies failed because the owners of
those companies were uh dishonest people
that speculated with their customers
money and did not know what they were
doing they were Crooks and uh I I have a
very very strong opinion about being
comp in this industry to those that take
those unnecessary risks so a quick
sidebar uh when this original bill was
passed um I don't remember when it was
passed but um the original legislation
that this house bill seeks to amend was
what
3397 I I spoke in opposition to the bill
then and the primary reason I did at the
time is that the point I wanted to make
is that those in this industry that are
have been dishonest that have taken
advantage of uh New Hampshire consumers
don't follow the rules um your the the
regulations the rules and the laws won't
prevent bad people from operating
dishonest business and and not following
through uneven contractual obligations
as a small business owner and
entrepreneur of a New Hampshire owned
company I can tell you that we have a
rich tradition of compliance um we know
that we have to follow the rules it puts
us sometimes at a disadvantage
competitively when we're competing
against huge companies that don't a
point that I will offer um to to support
that statement is that we we're aware
it's at my company simple energy we
compete with am maragas we are aware
that they have a problem um I I'm not
going to misrepresent that companies
that falter and fail fail represent a
certain opportunity to an entrepreneur
that owns propane trucks and employees
propane technicians and drivers we we
like to think that we we're positioned
to take good advantage of that right but
I know that that company is struggling
um the reality is there's a law in place
that requires any company in the state
of New Hampshire to register with the uh
Secretary of State's office annually
that we are uh poised to offer pre-bi
contracts we sign an affidavit it's got
my signature on it that says I I got
this I'm going to cover my you can trust
me I'll follow the law I'm going to
cover these
uh contracts with the using the rules in
this
legislation am mergas isn't listed there
they're they're not on they're not
already following the law from what I
can tell I'm I'm not in law enforcement
but I went to the website uh long ago to
find out you know who's who's playing by
the rules and who isn't and I can tell
you they're not alone they're not the
only company operating in the Upper
Valley that's not registered to sell
preby that sells pre- buby contracts um
there is a gentleman my first experience
with this by the way uh to let me I'll
sidebar again was in 1993 there was a a
gentleman that had a startup business in
uh the Lakes region of New Hampshire
that was offering preby that year I
remember it very distinctly 499 was the
number now who Among Us would not jump
on a 499 preby right now well my
response to that is any intelligent
human being that understands that if
something appears too good to be true it
probably is and despite my feeling that
way there were thousands of people that
bought that contract including a second
cousin of mine that lives in Falmouth
somehow this ended up being my fault
from his perspective but the rest of the
commodity Community those of us that
were were dealers I was working for Dead
River on the coast of main at the time
our our pre- buby price was $999 or just
over a dollar a gallon as much as I'd
like to go back there the reality is
someone sold a dollar commodity for
dollar commodity for 50s and told the
people whose money he collected that
they could trust him and he would
deliver well not long after that he was
living in his parents basement he was
gone that same individual right now will
sell you a propane tank on Facebook
Marketplace and I know this because as a
small business entrepreneur that's part
of a wildly competitive industry I make
it my business to know what others are
offering and how they're doing it
compared to what I'm doing at the risk
of sounding very arrogant I am an expert
at risk management I am an expert at
fulfilling even the unexpressed wishes
of my customers if I were not I would
not be here you your your rules are are
something that we have a rich tradition
of following I said that already but the
things the the let me jump around here a
little bit bear with me because I wanted
to I'll spare you my
rambling so when representative ative uh
rung spoke there were a couple of things
that she said that really resonated with
me that I agree with one of the first
statements she made is that she asked
around her town and looked at social
media there are literally if I brought
them with me I would show you an
impressive stack of paper thousands of
comments inquiries suggestions reviews
that we are as a small business uh I'm
bombarded with on a daily basis I have a
full-time employee that just monitors
Yelp reviews Google reviews Facebook
reviews townwide list serves and I'll
tell you why the average consumer does
not fundamentally understand the risk
they take when they sign these contracts
we tell them that in giant boldface
online flashing signs that say we will
not take unnecessary risk with your
money but we are handcuffed to these
contracts the second we follow the law
and buy them we can't just let you out
of them because you feel like you made a
bad decision is sympathetic as I am I
just can't do that my suppliers won't
allow that and I'm legally obligated to
fulfill those contracts and I personally
guarantee the finance of those which is
millions of dollars it if if you're if
that doesn't scare the pee out of you
you're not a scarel human being and and
I'll I'll put my neck even further out I
would invite anyone on this committee
including uh the representative to come
to my office and I will show you
effective risk management the risk that
the consumer ultimately takes is
disproportionate to the risk that I take
not by a little it is huge it can wipe
me out it can devastate me personally if
I get it wrong it's it's not a guess it
is not something that we take lightly
it's also not a problem if you look
across the landscape of our uh of our
industry today we're not losing
companies like we did between 07 and 09
well let me let me put you in the time
machine between 07 and 09 there was was
a perfect storm brutally cold Winters
very very tightening Supply wild
volatility in the Commodities market and
the prediction the experts that said
this is where the future markets are
going to be including companies like
Goldman Sachs they were wrong and what
we saw is crude oil at 146 followed by
crude oil at 35 like that and if you
weren't properly hedged and you were
speculating in that market you were gone
right well my company was four years old
when that happened and even my smart
friend said are you nuts and I said no
I'm not nuts I'm smart enough to know
that taking risk in a market driven
commodity is not a place where you mess
around okay couple more comments I want
to make and then I'll then I'll stop
talking I promise so the representative
that that represent or that uh is
proposing this uh bill um also talked
about things like uh accountability and
I again I couldn't agree more but the
the company that we're that we're
talking about or the companies that I
would argue are responsible for the
majority of the complaints are already
not accountable and they're they're
breaking laws that already exist we know
who they are if you if you talk to the
dealers uh and you know my good friend
Dave Rashard that's here as well he'll
tell you I I think he'll tell you the
same story that we know who's not
following the rules adding more of a
regulatory burden to the shoulders of
those of us who are already complying
does not help it gives the bad guys a a
continued unfair Advantage because
despite your best efforts and I I
applaud I work with Jim buffetti really
really closely uh and the entire Hassen
Administration even though I didn't wano
in 2014 when when our industry was in in
crisis and and my peers and the the
folks that work for me we covered it we
Rose to the occasion and we took care of
uh New Hampshire residents we know what
we're doing
um the other thing that comes up a lot
in in uh in this whole discussion
particularly when we start talking about
propane is people yes people are
frustrated by fees fees fees fees fees
simple energy has a very strict pricing
philosophy where we put all of our fees
in your price per gallon there is no
there's no hidden fee that's just me I
can't speak for the whole industry but I
that's part of my transparent pricing
strategy it works really well for me
it's consistent with my name we've had a
lot of Success With It 18 years in a row
we've been growing but my experience is
that companies that have a lot of fees
often times have a really low price
great introductory offer we compete on
price all the time it's a commodity
right so people will call me Rob how can
you compete with the big guys with the
Irvings the Dead Rivers and I'm like
they they can't compete with me it's a
market driven commodity I'm buying from
the same rail head on the same open
market I'm taking the same risk the
difference is I got way more skin in the
game so I'm way more motivated to
succeed I got no fallback I got
everything I own on the line here so who
do you want working for you do you got
to do your homework you got to know who
you're asking to to honor their side of
the contract but but I also am going to
push back and say when you and I do when
you write me a check when you give me
the money and there's consideration for
our agreement you have to bear the
responsibility for know what you're
signing up for I'm happy to go through
the details of those terms and
conditions I I feel like our industry
does an adequate job and it's why I
oppose further trying to regulate
something that won't really fix the
underlying problem I do have a couple
more comments and then I promise I'm I'm
done uh there were a few things um that
the gentleman from the Attorney
General's office talked about I feel
very strongly that uh independent fuel
dealers are not the PR department of the
AG's office we already do an incredible
job pushing and pushing and pushing
people to make sure they understand the
risk um like I said giant boldface
italics we make it flash on the website
we send them postcards we we we can't be
expected to displace meaningful terms
and conditions with this is how you
contact the consumer protection board if
you're not happy um about a a contract I
I don't feel like that's our
responsibility um when we talk about
enforceability I'm with you 100% but I
know who's in my backyard I know who my
competitors are you they're already not
complying I actually there's two small
guys in my in my marketing area that I'm
certain are 100% unaware that this
legislation even exists yet they're
offering budget and preby plan and I can
predict the future I'm not no stradamus
but I will tell you that I can I can see
where this is going all right fieldings
Rumford uh Fuller FNS in Connecticut big
one $300 million company gone boom
overnight guess why they didn't play by
the rules didn't know what they were
doing all right two more quick
points uh propane tanks so uh 50% of my
portfolio is propane the average
investment that I make at your home when
I put a 500 gallon tank th000 gallon
tank in the ground to provide central
heat cooking generator whatever it is is
on order of about
$7,000 so you're right there's a lot of
a lot of people representative hunt that
don't charge for that it it's
unfortunately part of the competitive
nature that we operate in as a small guy
imagine what that does for in terms of
you know cash flow demand just think
about starting a propane company if you
don't have a million bucks to buy tanks
excavators higher techs regulator piping
you don't start cuzz the big guys will
do it all for nothing guess why they
want to hold on to you that's the it's
the golden handcuffs that we want to put
on those customers so this is this is a
little bit of you know full disclosure
open kimono we do make it hard our
industry makes it hard for you to leave
us oftentimes for the wrong reason my
attitude is well if I can't keep you
I'll help you go I put all my effort
into making sure you're going to stay
but that's me that's my competitive
Advantage the industry in general does
not make this very easy for the consumer
and I get that but please consider for a
moment that those 60-day transactions
you're looking for have thousands of
dollars of value assigned to them and
you're asking two companies in the heat
of a season to not only negotiate what
the asset buyout is going to be but to
TTI but potentially disrupt and already
very very busy schedule to go SCT tanks
that might occur before the new tanks
are set which is a complaint I don't
know that you've had yet but a portion
of my portfolio is in the state of
Vermont there is a similar law in the
state of Vermont and that law called
cf111 it's a consumer protection
legislation it's good legislation it it
does help but one of the unintended
consequences is because there's this
tight deadline of customer notifies you
you go get the tanks you weigh the tanks
measure the tanks give them the credit
back if my company does that very
efficiently and I do and my competitor
who has a ton of fees but a really good
price doesn't I go pick up my tanks
within 30 days and they haven't set
their tanks
yet find me a consumer that's going to
be happy about that transaction because
they can't cook they can't heat there's
no hot water and who's the bad guy I am
so be careful of the unintended
consequences of adding earmarks and
legislation uh or adding additional um
compliance notes to this legislation you
I'm happy to do it with you we'll great
things happen when dealers work with the
regulatory Community that's I'm not here
to say I don't want to work with you
guys I do but let's do it the right way
thanks for your
time okay we have questions from the
committee members representating MCU
thank you very much and thanks for being
one of the one of the good ones it
sounds like thank you appreciate it you
sound like the kind of guy I'd want to
do business with uh if if I did if you
were in our area um
unfortunately sometimes we have to
legislate for the least common
denominator so my my question is what
does it cost now if a consumer calls you
a customer calls and said I'm sorry I
want to change change tanks and what
what do you charge them to take it out
if anything service fees maybe nothing
for the removal but some other service
fee how long does it take all that stuff
yeah great question I appreciate that
I'm sorry to talk over you it's a that's
just part of my anxiety I personally I
don't charge anything I it's uh I I have
been advised that I should there you
know when when I look at the industry
you know there are lots of peer groups
that say well you know you got to get
something you know like I said before I
can on average it's A5 to $7,000
investment that I have so if you're a
,000 a year client and I'm at a dollar
margin round numbers right I'm seven
years before I'm breaking even on the
investment to put the infrastructure now
the good news is in year eight making
money that's the whole nature of the of
the propane gas business not only that
but my assets are on your property we're
so we're we're sort of married at that
point but if I can't keep you happy and
you want to change if I want to push the
issue I still look like the bad guy now
I've lost a customer and I'm kicking you
on the way out the door that never works
I don't know any company that uh would
ever get your your business back or that
would you would speak favorably about on
the local list serve um but the the real
cost at a minimum I'm mobilizing a very
experienced very expensive CDL driver
generally could be a Class A or Class B
driver driving a Hazmat vehicle with
operating heavy equipment to remove
those tanks there are regulations
surrounding where and when I can move
those tanks if they have product in them
so you know the regulatory checklist
starts to pile up and as it does in
order to uh satisfy all of those
requirements and the scheduling can I
give you a number that's two 300 bucks
an hour just to put someone in Motion in
a vehicle so let alone that now I have
to recapture the asset and if I can
replace the asset you know back in the
field great but that's another you know
uh sort of unbillable uh transaction so
it's crazy expensive the the goal has to
be keep I'll tell you my mission keep
you buying keep the asset on your
property make you
happy charge he doesn't charge we we
don't some some do but we don't we do
not okay thank you very much for your
testimony pleasure okay uh David Richard
energy and I hope he said some things
you were going to say so you can be a
little bit
[Laughter]
shorter yeah I'll keep my testimony
simple great perfect um my name is David
rishard and I'm with DF rishard energy
in do and Hampshire we were founded in
1932 by my grandfather um we do business
a lot like Rob we're very simple as far
as we try to maintain people's
relationships it is all about
relationships and no hidden fees and no
um we try to do everything upfront with
people and we try to maintain that my
grandfather started the company that way
with a handshake and we still do things
the same way to this day um the only
fees that we do have regarding propane
tanks is for we do have a usage fee for
a generator but everything else we take
our pride to um size of Tanks
appropriately so we have the right usage
through there so we get our return on
our investment and the customer is happy
so there's no hidden fees on the
backside where they complain after on
the
backside um now as far as the pre- buby
program we're very um simple with in
regards to that price per gallon um and
uh how many gallons you want to reserve
for the year now the only other see you
don't charge a fee up front no we don't
charge a fee up front but we do have a
downside protection if you want to um um
combat that if the price goes down but
everything is in writing terms and
customer knows exactly what they're
getting
into that's great um as far as picking
out propane tanks and whatnot we have a
department that's really great we
monitor um any customers that are
non-usage and whatnot and we will um
send out technicians and whatnot to go
on the road and investigate see what's
going off if the house was sold and
whatnot um so we do we don't want our
assets out there being unused for too
long it's too much of investment on our
end so we do try to retrieve those as
quick as possible but if there is a
situation where there's going to be some
ovap we're not going to take the tanks
until the other company has retrieved
this because we don't want them to have
any freeze ups or without heat so we do
work with a customer on a on a b uh on
base base by base uh
basis yeah so how often are you actually
digging the tank or you just working out
with the other propane company and and
right right so we're talking about one
company here and that's why we're all
here but 95% of the time we will uh
contract out with another provider and
they'll send us an invoice we'll
purchase a tank off them and there's no
it's seamless perfect thank you thanks
we do have a question representative
spear realizing that 49 folks are really
good at this and very reliable and
trustworthy to their customers but
realizing that the
largest person that operates in in the
uh in the area played all kinds of games
is the legislation that we're proposing
here that's being proposed here it it
doesn't seem to me to be burdensome so I
wanted to get your take on it I'm a big
proponent to a free market if I think
people should educate themselves on what
they're getting into and you know we
have a good job we do a good job of
policing other providers so if am
educating our customers as to what
they're getting into and they can
compare apples to apples and whatnot and
see if it's more advantageous to go with
us or versus the other customer or the
other
provider representative Cole thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question so there certain months out of
the year in New England that you can't
take up these tanks because of the frost
right and what's the longest period of
time that you've experienced that has it
been like to four months say I'd say
yeah me Sometimes in April so the 60-day
requirement in here really doesn't work
it makes it difficult with the
underground tank yes thank
you okay representative
Herbert I think I heard
uh that
um some of the companies in the past
have gotten into financial difficulties
and gone bankrupt y because they took
the customers cash flow and and uh
speculated on uh uh the price of the
Commodities they're dealing in and they
bought when they should have sold but
the so what is there anything is there
anything that we can legislate that
would stop uh your particular industry
from taking cash and putting it into
speculation I think that would really be
a hindrance on the all of us people that
are doing things the right way we're
we're really working hard to buy the
product at a good rate that we can pass
on to the customer and we're locking in
a rate on our end so uh we're trying to
do the same thing and pass it on to the
customer so if you read page two yeah
that's the stuff we
did to address that problem so we are
that we already addressed that problem
several years so they're they're
actually not they're breaking the law
that these people if we've got a a
Prohibition on doing that and they are
doing it uh why wouldn't uh our uh uh
attorney general uh crack down we're
providing we have a contract and we're
going through with that contract that we
are providing for the customer price per
gallon and we're not bearing from that
on our
end well that's fine but some people
apparently are but I feel like that
might be punishing the rest of us that I
feel like we can kind of police
ourselves as an industry and people
would come to us because we are doing
things the right
way
okay
W representative wals then
representative
mcor thank you Mr chairman forgive me if
perhaps you're not the right person to
ask but do you know if there's anywhere
in the state of New Hampshire where
there is a
monopoly that exists of just one
provider for
propane no we we have 50 of us that are
providing propane in the state right now
so there's no town There's No District
there's no area that is a monopoly not
as far no
okay all right it's a very competitive
market right well my question is you
know this would prevent any you know um
evildoers if that were the case you know
what I'm saying thank
you and representative m uh thank you Mr
chairman both you and the previous
speaker spoke about that 60-day problem
um is it possible and I I look at the uh
the writer of this legislation if we
excluded um heating months and so it
would be 60 days outside of heating
months in other words you wouldn't have
to let's say from November through April
you wouldn't have to remove a tank would
that work number one number two is there
any other thing in this leg legislation
that you think is uh garious to your
your
business I think it's a little
burdensome to the industry right now I
again I'm a free market type of guy I
really believe in going with that as far
as we don't really need a lot of it um
legislation and mandates to operate the
right way in the
state I understand your side but we're
not you know people that are doing
things the right way people will
gravitate towards doing business with
them okay thank you very much you have
one card less Leslie Anderson who
represents the propane gas Association
of New
England so you you replaced Rose I did I
replaced Rose thank you I could bring
his milk jug though if that would be
helpful well you say hi for him I
will uh good afternoon my name is lesli
Anderson I'm the president of the
propane gas you need to pull the mic a
little closer I'm the my name is leslee
Anderson I'm the president president of
the propane gas Association of New
England and uh we operate um here in New
Hampshire for the and our members
include the 50 um companies that sell
propane here across the state including
the one that we've been trying not to
mention um I I will say that they are
signaling that their residential
business is for sale uh and and
hopefully this problem will take care of
of itself uh that has been out
there um I also one of the things our
association does is we we do work with
any c consumer complaints customers find
our our number if they have problems and
I will interact and go directly to the
heads of the companies and talk with
them and if any of you ever have a
problem um as I've offered to um the
representative sponsoring this bill
please feel free to reach out to our
association and we will work to
facilitate and solve that problem as
quickly as possible um when we've had
deep freezes we've had the governor call
us and ask us to deliver to people that
haven't paid their bill in 9 months you
know but they had kids at home and we
can make things happen um when they need
to because we all care about the
consumers and our customers here in New
Hampshire so please use us as a resource
if you ever have any issue um one of the
the main things uh that we have a
problem with about this bill is it's
taking a pre-bi and a guaranteed price
plan statute that was put in place after
the events that Rob discussed earlier
where we had the problem s with Fred
Fuller in the state and and it required
dealers to lock in the gallon so if
you're going to sell 100 gallons preby
you've got to lock in 75 of those
gallons and you've got to file a form
that goes to the state each year saying
how you locked them in and the way you
lock them in is by buying future
contracts and the buying future
contracts has a price and some of our
members roll that into their price some
of them put that as a pre-bi pro you
know price so the idea about prorating
this pre-bi fees that's the flat fee and
if somebody pro-rated it they probably
just broke it up monthly to make it
easier on the payments that were there
so so that section needs to come out
because that's a fixed price and that's
what drives what that is and I I think
you guys have have come to that
conclusion through the testimony um
that's gone on um but we've taken this
pre-bi and guaranteed plan and we've
thrown a bunch of other stuff into the
mix on the third line we we've added
contracts for petroleum and so now we're
saying all petroleum products have to
adhere to the rules we put in place just
for pre- buying guaranteed price
programs and that's that's a problem
because um down in section
two uh it says that you have to have the
price per gallon in every contract that
you have well you'd want that for a
pre-bi a guaranteed price ban but now we
might be increasing costs if we apply
this to all petroleum products because
because one of the most common types of
pro uh of programs that our dealers do
is they give you a cap price they say
we're going to charge you 350 a gallon
but if the price in the market goes down
you can get the lower cost uh so I'm
just weary about expanding this to all
contracts for petroleum because now
we're tying in with all these
requirements that we put together for
pre-bi and for for um guaranteed price
plans and I think that's going to cause
some problems and it might incre
increase prices because people will say
I can't offer a a a cap price because I
I don't know what that price is going to
be if it goes down where are you what
are where are you looking at so in line
three it ex it adds and contracts for
petroleum and I would take that out and
and limit this to the pre- buby and the
guaranteed price programs that are there
in contract I Goa in contract yeah okay
um the the other um area that really
concerned me was the underground tanks
um and specifically for for tank
removals the 60-day tank
removals um most of our members pick up
their tanks within two weeks or within
30 days uh and that's because they're
expensive and they don't want that asset
sitting out there not doing anything for
their business uh it's very competitive
business they don't want the tanks out
there
so 60 days I think is a is a good time
except that there's problems right
there's problems in the wintertime and
there's especially problem with
underground tanks so if this was to move
forward at all we would want to have
this apply only to above ground tanks
underground tanks the ground's frozen
you need to coordinate you've got
Landscaping issues mud season I mean
there's all these things that surround
underground tanks uh and normally what
happens is those tanks are transferred
they're either sold to the customer or
they're sold to another uh propane
marketers that's taking over the account
but we would want to exclude underground
tanks from any kind of so it says or
make every reasonable effort that that
the the AG's office want to yank that
out we should leave that in for just
underground no I would take I would just
add to remove their above ground tanks I
wouldn't even include underground tanks
in this
requirement uh the the majority of the
complaints that come in are about above
ground tanks they're not about
underground tanks so I would exclude
those oh I see okay and I would leave in
the reasonable attempt because there's
tanks on islands where where you may
have to go out and get them when the ice
is frozen you know I mean
there's there's tanks on camps that you
can't access certain times of the year
they so TR you know the the dealer can
show a good attempt I think to try to
get their tanks within that certain
amount of time but there's a lot of
Mother Nature that factors into that
more than anything else the other thing
is it should not be from the contract
termination date that you have to pick
up your tank it should be a not no
ification requests to come pick up your
tank from the customer or from the the
company that's taking over the account
and I say that because you may terminate
your contract today but you've got 50%
in your tank and you want to use the
remaining gallons and then switch to a
new dealer and so I don't know how long
it's going to take you to use those
gallons you know if you're just one
person on your own it might take a
couple months uh if you're a big family
it might take two weeks but the clock
doesn't really start ticking until uh
you want that tank picked up so it
should be a notification date from from
then um and and I think above ground 60
days with a reasonable attempt is is
fine um although I would prefer as my
members on the whole would prefer that
that we not expand this regulation and
that we really not move it forward um
but I did want to want to add that well
it says right now is or written notific
of discontinuance of the contract but
you might discontinue your contract and
then use up the propane that's left in
your tank
before you're ready to have your tank
picked up so it needs to be a notice to
remove your tank a request for the owner
to remove their
tank okay yeah
okay all right um still going
um I mentioned we have over 50 members
they're very competitive um the
complaints that we do get are usually
about how much their price per gallon is
these are the most frequent complaints
that um usually come in from the AG's
office if they contact me about
something and it's simply based on how
much you use you know the investment
that's out there that we have um I've
had a lot of complaints about people
that have propane for generators only
that the more and more electric get gets
moving and people move to heat pumps and
other things everybody's putting in
generators for propane and you have to
charge a tank rental or a minimum gallon
usage per year to make up your
investment if you have tanks at a
generator account uh because you've got
that investment of about $3,000 sitting
there at the customer's location so
there's frequently a charge for a tank
rental or a minimum usage fee if you're
not using propane for home heat for
cooking for hot water for pool heaters
for everything else um and we get lots
of complaints about that but the reason
is because there's so much investment
there by the company owning those above
ground tanks yeah but I remember the old
days and and the complaint was that they
paid more for the tank to be filled than
a bigger tank so I'm confused is the
only thing I see is is we're Banning
somebody else owning that tank it's
still your yeah that doesn't make any
sense to me because you can't charge for
something you don't own right so so
therefore that that sentence really
doesn't mean anything to you because you
guys all own your own tanks we own our
own tanks I mean I don't know if that's
confusion because sold the tanks to
compan somebody thought that they that
they were doing and that's why it's in
the bill yeah you know because they
someone thought that um that somebody
else owned the tank but in terms of this
thing about the
fee did did where where did it say that
you couldn't charge a rental fee for a
propane tank owned by another company or
cons but that owned by another company
or consumer so so I don't know if that's
confusion because if you switch
companies sometimes the dealers will
sell tanks to the new provider rather
than go in and take out their tanks and
put in new tanks I don't know if that's
the confusion or if there has been
confusion um with some of the
Acquisitions as to whether the new way
sentence is written you really doesn't
bother you because you none of your guys
do that anyways no that's correct
perfect yeah all right thank you
represent I'd be glad to answer any
questions okay represent Amon I have two
quick ones
uh first one is uh how how could a
consumer know who who owns the
tank uh it'll say on the tank itself
inside they have to have the number of
who's supplying and it'll usually say
owned by this person that's there switch
that out I guess yeah I do get calls
from new homeowners sometimes that are
looking for documentation can't figure
out if they own it or if they don't own
it and I'll work with propane companies
to help them find out because the
companies will have them as listed as an
asset unless they've sold them and they
so you can usually go back to the
whoever the provider is and find out if
you if you bought the tank or not if it
wasn't specifically listed when you
purchased your home okay and then
followup question um how can a consumer
know uh a consumer seeking to switch
providers how can they find out what
providers service their their area all
of them U just going on the web and
looking all every every place um is
there and you can also go to propane.com
find a retailer and put your ZIP code in
and it'll print out based on everybody's
Google addresses in the state who's in
your area so propane.com is that you
you okay great thank thank you very much
U with that um
representative grai is um I want is
sheet okay um so how many people are
going to be testifying on 1491 other
sponsor okay so we'll we'll go ahead
then great
all
right okay representa spillsbury welcome
to the Commerce Committee sorry about
the delay but I'm sure you enjoyed
learning all about propane
contracts thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon members um representative
Terry spillsbury from Sullivan District
3 representing Charlestown Newport Unity
and yes I'm glad I was uh here for that
last discussion good
orientation on the kinds of
consumer protection uh Provisions that
you're uh
considering mine is in that same Zone
this is a simple direct consumer
protection measure it's narrowly
drawn so that it relates specifically to
heating fuel
delivery and
its
purpose is that whenever a customer
prepays I'm not talking about pre uh
payment contracts I'm talking about at
will customers who call the fuel
delivery company and make an arrangement
for the delivery of a certain quantity
of gallons on a certain date and pay at
that time so these are
customers who for whatever reasons are
not using pre-bond I are not uh on a
automated delivery schedule and do not
have credit terms in which case
typically the delivery is made and
there's 30 days within which to
pay so when a
customer calls let's say on a Monday and
says I'd like to arrange for 300 gallons
of heating fuel to be delivered to my
tank on Thursday
price is quoted on
Monday and that price is
paid that in terms of this bill is a
concluded
sale and this is one of those situations
I've become aware of I I know that it is
uh uh the common practice of one of the
largest fuel delivery companies in the
state I don't want to uh make any
representations about how pervasive it
is I just simply know that it should not
be allowed so why would we allow a
custom a a fuel delivery company to
reprice the
oil as following my example on the
Thursday if they already quoted a price
and collected full payment for that
price on the Monday and I know that this
inv volatile markets can be a few
pennies up it could even be a few
pennies down but in recent years it's
it's often been as much as even in the
space of several days a 20 to 50 Cent
swing so somebody orders 300 gallons and
all of a sudden finds on Thursday that
what he paid for on Monday is now $75
higher so I'll leave it there I think
it's straightforward
um and uh I'm actually pretty astounded
that this is not currently prohibited
well I I assume because you don't have
how many
days it it shouldn't make a difference
how many days when when the when the
price is quoted and the payment is made
that that under the terms constitutes a
concluded sale a concluded sale
meaning a sale agreed at a quoted price
and paid for at that price prior to
delivery whether the delivery is that
afternoon a week later or four months
later shouldn't make any difference
because you bought it so I'll just I
give you two thoughts that occur to me
um just by analogy it's hard to make a a
direct analogy but you know I go into
Macy's for bed sheets and they don't
have them in stock they say well we can
sell them to you now and we'll have them
delivered to your home I go into Staples
they don't have the printer ink they
don't have the the pens right I'm sure
we've all been there these are examples
that I'm personally familiar with can
you imagine the outrage from the
consumers in this world if somebody
walked into the Staples or the Macy's on
a Monday paid for it and then found on
the Thursday when the delivery arrived
that they owed
more outrageous it's inconceivable right
it's outrageous outrageous so please
help me by passing this bill pretty
straightforward okay thank you for
giving us a straightforward one okay oh
yes representative Amon has a question I
I know we're we're in lunchtime here um
could you just walk me through where
this bill idea came from and the
specifics of uh you know how did the
this occur to you or your constituent he
say he's an oil dealer that does
this so let's be specific um this has
occurred to me I choose not to be a
credit customer and this has occurred to
me for years and so I began speaking to
other people and I've had conversations
with 20 or 30 people to whom this has
occurred so it's you know it's not I'm
not just it's not just that I have a
chip on my shoulder it's that I I have
exists and and we can we can often be
talking about um price differentials in
a matter of days that are $50 to
$100 okay representative
Walsh thank you Mr chairman how is this
different from say me going to to buy
gas one day at$ 2.99 and then the next
day I see that it went down to 283 or
something how is that different so on
the you're you're talking about you're
talking about your your automobile the
payment and the delivery
coincided so the here's the point so
you're your last bill you were
discussing uh pre-bi contracts and one
of the the fellows who testified talked
about who takes the risk of price
fluctuations that occur after the sale
agreement which may have occurred in
July and deliveries in January and
February so the the point is that the
consumer who has made the payment on the
Monday should not be the party that's
taking the price risk of fluctuations
that occur between Monday and
Thursday and when you go to your gas
station with your car you pay you decide
whether to drive away or to take the gas
and you get the delivery
simultaneously but if you did like a
layway and you waited a month to pick up
delivery should maybe you have to pay a
storage fee from them holding on to your
your should be in the contract that
should
be well we would write it in the bill
this this is not a contract situation
this is not you're he paid but he says
okay I'm paying I'm going to give you
this money and but I don't want you to
deliver it until two months from now
well I don't I don't know if an oil
company would do that so I think you're
you're well that's what I'm saying
because we started out with you had this
simple little scenario a couple of days
yes and then I said well what about but
and you said well what happens if it's a
month later okay so if if it is a month
later let's say that it is some you have
a bunch of bunch of constituents bunch
of people who really pay attention to
the oil company and the oil company puts
out an outrageously row low price that
day okay and everybody says oh yeah
let's get in on that let's get in on
that now that company has got to hold
that oil for that you know period of
time that person says but I don't want
delivery yet my tank is full I want to
lock in that price for you to deliver to
me a month so so it's a it's a
fascinating hypothetical that I cannot
imagine actually occurring because no
rational Oil Company would would offer
that proposition or would put them
themselves at risk for that long but if
they did they should be bound
they should be
bound so you said on year later I want
you I want to lock in this price for
next year it's not the purpose of our
consumer protection statutes to protect
the provider of the oil from idiotic
marketing decisions it's the purpose to
protect the consumer from being taken
advantage okay so so I'm saying is I
don't have a problem with your issue
yeah it but it if as long as the
delivery date is within a week but when
you start pushing the delivery date out
I do think you're creating uh you're
creating a a a more problematic
solution if you put a date on it I think
the stat the the bill is still worth
passing great if you put a date on it I
would think two weeks might be a little
bit more sensible okay I don't think you
need to put a date on it right uh
because I think that oil companies won't
offer to hold the oil for longer periods
of time they only have so much storage I
think I would assume okay representative
weeks no I just I think it's I it's
let's leave that as they used to say in
my town gr leave it go let but I have a
question and that is if uh this is this
has occurred you've told us that this
has
occurred has this been tested it all in
the in the courts has somebody said I
agreed to pay such and such for so much
oil the company agreed I agreed I paid
and then when they delivered two days
later they charged me they sent me a
bill for the difference has anybody bed
at this and
lost I don't know I haven't done that
research well does that mean that
they've actually paid and then said
nothing and complain I would bet
and we have someone come up here who
will testify tell us why this is a bad
Bill okay he's opposed to it but I will
bet that the oil company said to the
consumer at the
time that we can't guarantee this price
if you wait to if you're waiting for a
later delivery other words you're you're
but what we're going to do is we're
going to treat your payment as a
deposit but that it could be higher if
that by the time we delivered it to you
because you're asking for a week or
whatever that it could be hire so be be
prepared for it to might be H since I'm
testifying in part on my personal
experience I can assure you that no such
representation or even a hint of it has
ever been made there you go
okay all right we do have another
question remember M thank you Mr
chairman so was it at your request that
that the delivery was LA or would you
have taken it at the time of payment
like say they had a truck in the
neighborhood like two houses down and
you just happen to call them you you
consummate the sale fully completed
right offer acceptance payment whatever
and they so we'll be there in five
minutes that's a very good question I'll
I'll just testify in terms of my
personal experience rather than trying
to characterize a lot of disparate
situations in charl
town my oil company delivers once weekly
and you can only get a delivery on
Thursday if you choose to be a will call
customer you're watching your oil tank
you're gauging how much you're going to
need how much your Tank's going to take
you're making your own commercial
decision you may even be watching the
fluctuations of the prices dayto day and
decide which day to make the call and
you may decide to call the Friday before
or the Tuesday to get a delivery for
that cycle so it is entirely
based on the limitations of delivery and
I can tell you that if it were up to me
and I could wave a wand and have the oil
delivered the day I paid I would be
delighted but you have to work within
the logistical constraints that the oil
company presents
you yeah so so so essentially if I
understand you correctly you'd like to
shift the risk from the consumer to to
the other commodity the commodity
broker the risk on the fluctuating price
I I'd like the risk I I shift I'm going
to I'm going to hesitate to adopt that
word when the sale is
concluded the risk is on the oil company
under this bill and and they get to
decide which day they're going to serve
your town um imagine the payment on a
pre-bi contract in July and and then the
oil company can change the price on you
it defeats the whole point of the pre-
buby so if the consequence of this
legislation is that they will refuse to
do business with you or say it's only a
deposit would this bill still be worth
it well I do think the bill would be
worth it I I think it's it's an improper
contractual relationship that should be
illegal uh what they may do as a
reaction uh shutting off customers and
so on May may require further thought if
it if that actually
unfolds okay thank you very much thank
you okay
Rob we have
okay yeah now you're gonna be brief yeah
okay I've been I've been adequately
cautioned thank you no that the last
part was brief then we're worried
um I'm all about it we support it
will'll work with you but the when you
talk about risk I'm I know that you are
un people in general are unaware of the
risk behind that transaction the product
in a storage tank is generally part of a
supply contract that the dealer is held
to and it is monetized every single day
every minute of every day that the
commodity is trading the value of the
oil in storage is monetized by a market
price we you can't ask us to hold a
price forever if you are not willing to
take delivery without some other
discussion about a fee or some sort of
risk instrument that that because that's
what we do we hedge retail fuel in our
storage tanks to prevent things like in
2008 well that's what I'm saying go back
to the thought was the reason Fuller
went under but was all I heard was the
Articles the articles I was reading is
how this guy said I spent all day long
all I'm doing is online dealing with my
price and and this was an oil problem
not a gas problem it's it's not two
cents and and in that in those market
conditions which are could happen
tomorrow the the price moved 60 cents in
a minute on the Commodities exchange we
were buying in that environment if
you're asking me to guarantee a price to
profit margin by the way average retail
profit margin that year 43 cents a
gallon so I'm you're asking me to
operate in a in a market where I can go
upside down with no if if someone's dumb
enough to do it we're going to be
talking about other legislation to keep
Bad actors from making promises they
can't deliver we'll work with you you
got to there's got to be a limit a
company like mine I turn my inventory
every two days so it's monetized for two
days and then I bring more in and the
price changes and it changes throughout
the day our wholesalers there are only
two in New Hampshire big wholesalers at
the coast we get routinely midday price
changes for product that we're going to
pick up at the coast nothing I can do
about that my truck can be in line about
to load and they go nope 5 cents more
boom just like that can be 10 cents more
it can be 20 cents more it just doesn't
work without timing so what is the right
timing I mean for me it's a day it's
today it's same day you want same day
delivery you want to paid for it up
front I'll give you a great price but
you got to you got I got to transfer
otherwise you're GNA say you can give
your credit card but that's a deposit if
you want some wiggle room I I think that
the industry I don't speak for everyone
even though Dave and Bob I'll tell you I
do all the time a couple of days you
know if I had the you know the whole
Council here we go what do you guys want
to do a couple of days we can hold it we
can legitimately hedge that but the
reality is that all goes to hell on a
hand basket pardon my expression when
you have a war that starts right and all
of a sudden they go bam shut down the
coast shut down trading and the next
time they open the spet for us to go
load our trucks the pric is up 6070
cents a gallon we have seen this happen
it was part of what contributed to the
failure that we talked about before
exactly okay now representative Terry do
you want or you want oh okay repres
thank you Mr chairman uh if
you I believe the answer is real simple
if somebody calls you up and says I want
to give you I want 300 gallons of oil I
want to pay you today yes and I want you
to deliver on Thursday all you got to
say is I won't accept your money only
going to price it on delivery it's it's
that simple it's that simple you don't
you don't make the
deal I think that's what will happen if
we pass this
bill so what that's what we do now and
that's that's how my company operates
you to to his point if you call me and
my your delivery is next Thursday but I
I know the risk I know what I have in
storage I can calculate the risk in my
head and I evaluate that 300 gallons at
worst case scenario I occasionally sell
a couple gallons of oil at a loss it
happens all the time and then we make it
up on the next Buy on the next load it's
just part of how the margin dynamics of
daily trading uh oil work okay great
question oh represent
SP the case that was brought to us was a
case where the oil or gas what whatever
commodity it was uh can only be
delivered on Thursdays
correct if that's the
case are you suggesting that the person
should only purchase the oil oil on a on
an as call basis on Thursday morning or
can they purchase it on
Tuesday what order it on Tuesday but if
he can't take
THS be dely
because he won't take your money you'll
wait until they deliver it on that
Thursday and they'll hang that coupon on
your door and you'll pay in 30 days yeah
I I I would I would evaluate the
individual risk which is VE very simple
for those of us that do this every day
it's slam dunk I go great see you next
Thursday there's your price you'll pay
what's on the ticket um in this case it
is a you're you're prepaying me right
now but you're not taking custody there
is a company that's a it's not a startup
they're owned by a big conglomerate
operating in New Hampshire their whole
platform is Click fill it's all online
it's all prepaid the number one
complaint from uh those customers are
it's a great price but when I order they
don't show up for6 seven days and then
they change the price and I go well no
kidding it's well that you can but but
you and I think you should but it
doesn't mean that we need a law
governing that because I have no crystal
ball I cannot tell without without a
time limit that you're you're allowing
today I guess uh that company to say
sure give me your money give me your
credit card number see you next week and
then they're changing the price someone
gets upset about it I
I don't know how to address that I
wouldn't do that I would tell you I
can't go that far out take delivery
tomorrow or the next day no
problem represented grassy yeah I I
think what I'm seeing in this bill and
what you're talking about here and I I
think makes sense and is that if someone
was to order if I was to place an order
for you for oil today yeah and I said
and you give me a price this is what the
oil is today but you say I can't deliver
it until Monday right I shouldn't that
price shouldn't change for
me if I if I told you that I wanted to
pay for G oil today but I don't want you
to deliver it to me for two weeks now
that's on me and if the price changes I
should be held responsible so in
principle I I agree with you
representative that if if I accept those
terms as you laid them out it I am I am
accepting that level of risk what I'm
telling you is if you put that into into
law I'm opposed to that because there's
no time sensitive I don't want to be
forced to because I if I make that
decision I'm taking the risk but there
are market conditions outside of my
control that could cause me to say well
are you going to support me when I say
Force meure I can't do it because that's
what that company's going to do F
further question if if you have if you
know if you take my order today yeah and
and you may not have the trucks to get
it out to me or whatever but you know
you have that oil in stock or in your in
your tanks at your store you should
should be able to honor that price for
money or you can tell me I can't sell it
to you today correct which is what I
would tell you I would say I'm going to
put you on a schedule at this price that
dot dot dot if there are unforeseen
market conditions I may not be able to
it'll be but but guess what what if the
price goes down are you going to expect
me to sell it to you at a lower price
I'll answer for you you are because
that's been my experience over my career
so you can't have it both ways where
you're asking me to take the risk I'll
take the risk if I sign up for it I'll
take it you put it into a law I'm going
to fight you on it 100% of the time
because I have to manage that risk for
everyone and you're forcing me to I I
think that companies that enter into
that agreement are wildly irresponsible
they're doing it right now in New
Hampshire you don't know it he's doing
it because he got a great price I don't
mean to speak for you but that's that's
my experience right I go online I get a
better price than yours Rob I go go
ahead and then a week later they get the
delivery price went up because they
never call me if the price went down
price goes up they get a new delivery
and they call and pissed and I go well
do do you do you own a 401k do you look
at the value of the 401K every day it's
the same transaction except it's more
heavily regulated and more expensive on
the physical gallon so I give you a day
this has been a very wild day
today I feel I feel my my uh propane
prices go up or down today thank you
very much my pleasure is there anybody
else would like to speak on this bill uh
has everybody got an idea what they want
to do all right thank you all very
much okay so uh how far behind are we
um okay let's yeah we can be back by by
okay
1144 relative requirements for sewage
Disposal Systems information to be
disclosed during a real estate
transaction is this your bill whose bill
is uh
11 44
oh okay now we're going to move to
sewage thank you uh thank you Mr
chairman um distinguished members of the
committee uh in my nine terms here I've
only appeared one other time and Mr
chairman you were here then way back
when so we going to do this again to get
this all day
long um I'm I'm here to uh introduce a
bill that was brought forward by the
Department of Environmental Services
subsurface House Bill uh
1144 uh requiring a certain information
disclosure of sewage Disposal Systems
during real estate transactions of
dwellings and Food Service
establishments uh for the record I uh
represent the good people of Carol
County 8 uh and in my my private life I
am a uh septic designer installer
evaluator excavation run a family
business we've been doing that for 30
years and it's pretty much all that we
do uh part of uh part of the of um my
profession uh besides designing and
installing is we do an enormous amount
of Waterfront assessments for transfers
of property for anything near a great
body of water a fourth order stream and
so forth and
um and I do a lot of work with the small
restaurants up in our area mom and pop
operations um and there is literally no
public sewer in my area I'm from the
freedom area below
Conway and Time After Time After Time
time uh someone will purchase a um a
diner um a small restaurant uh you might
have 30 40 seats in it and chefs I find
are very good at uh making food and
understanding how they price things but
most of most of the people uh that come
north have worked in locations that had
public sewer and just took for granted
when they bought a property and the and
the the owner owner told them oh yes we
have 100 seats and you might look inside
the restaurant there might be 80 or 90
seats but when it comes time to get
their new uh their new license food
license from the health department they
ask for the most current septic design
and at that time they find many times
that they're not licensed for 100
they're only licensed for 10 or 20 uh 20
seats it becomes a huge problem I I end
up going into at least 15 in my area
trying to work it out with them with
water meter readings and everything else
and over the course of many years
getting them up to maybe 40 seats when
they thought they had a
100 uh the second side of that um sword
is people that purchase a waterfront
property and their tax card may say they
have four and five
bedrooms and when they when they go to
look into the records after they
purchased it they find that they bought
a piece of land that big and all it will
support is two bedrooms the
grandfathered rate it becomes a big
issue once again on what to do so when
the department brought this forward to
me it seems reasonable and um I see it
as a great protection for the person
purchasing property whether it be a food
service or whether it be a
residence and I'm speaking here in favor
chairman questions from the
committee you work do you question do
you work with uh closely with rainy P
here at Dees with the Department yes dep
yep we
do he's been kicked upstairs he's he's
running the show Rainey has been at it
longer than your chairman yeah many and
I are all friends cuz I I'm the only
dam so okay so uh one thing we have
learned in this committee is that uh
when you do Food Services you have to
have a special septic system for the
food waste and and that's stre different
so but I guess what you're talking about
now is just how many people you can have
in the restaurant and that's more just
the basic bathrooms not not even that
food food service septics say right well
they the majority of uh the restaurants
are sized by the number of people
sitting and whether they're using if the
restaurant is using China something
that's washed or whether it's throw away
right and so Mo many places got licensed
a lot of years ago um you know saying
they were going to be paper service only
which is 20 gallons per day per seat but
then you know your place doesn't look
like uh the rits if you're giving them
paper plates so they switched over to
China and and the health yeah the health
department for many many years wasn't
monitoring this but now the department
they and department environmental servic
is very anxious because high strength uh
sewage with grease and everything else
is short circuiting and if you don't
have enough land and this is as big as
your Diner is you know that causes the
problem
okay seems simple
enough thank you very much thank
hlon
Dees
good afternoon good
afternoon thank you for allowing me to
testify in this bill um for the record
my name is Scott Hazelton I'm the
administrator of the subsurface systems
Bureau uh and I've been there for yeah
pull the mic closer to
closer how's that should pretend like
you're on
radio um yeah so I've I've been with the
subsurface systems Bureau just over six
months um I've been a licensed designer
since ' 04 and PRI of that um as a
highway director in one of the Upper
Valley regions
so the mark covered this very well and
I'm not going to uh reiterate some of
the things he said um but the so the
current RSA um limits the information um
that is required during a real estate
transaction um currently uh information
that's disclosed in a real estate
transaction is only required for one to
four family
dwellings um and the information that's
disclosed is is is uh includes the
septic systems
location any malfunctions that may have
occurred in with the system and the the
the uh contractor Andor pumper name and
the service dates of the
system and since I've been with it with
the dees subsurface Bureau um we receive
inquiries um from folks after they've
bought a property either residential or
a restaurant being
commercial and they are often surprised
uh by the number of bedrooms um that
their system will support
um for a residential transaction and uh
also they're often surprised to learn
that they may not be able to increase
the load on their system um due to the C
due to uh the current design and
property um for the sale uh for the sale
of commercial uh Food Service
establishment
structures they are regulated based on
the number of seats um that are
physically in the
restaurant and um in a few cases that
I've been aware of um as Mark said um
these folks uh don't don't understand
what the septic system is they only know
that it's out of sight out of mind and
until it doesn't function correctly they
don't pay attention to it but when they
contact us they they ask if their system
May support uh 100 seats like Mark said
where and in some cases they may not
have half those seats permitted for that
establishment um and so we end up with
some fairly upset owners new owners um
that can't uh support their business
with the increased number of
seats um so the proposed the proposal
for this is just
that more detailed information be
provided during the
transactions um and that
it'd be for all dwellings and uh Food
Service
establishments I think this is going to
and the the idea of this the intent of
this is
that a buyer would be given a copy of
the operational approval which includes
the design uh that's associated with the
structure on the
property which give them an an improved
knowledge of what he or she may be
buying
in the case of a uh residential
transaction um the number of bedrooms
are included on the design and they're
also included on the uh construction uh
approval and approval for operation that
receives for commercial construction
operation uh construction and
operational approvals um the number of
seats is included on the design um and
excuse
me and and typically the approvals and
the copies of of the designs are sent to
the towns via email or hard
copy and to support all of uh all of the
questions uh that a an owner Andor their
agent may
have the bureau has a is has an
individual that is called the reviewer
of the day which we we uh short for Rod
and that person is dedicated every day
to answer questions that may be received
from uh new homeowners new business
owners Andor um real estate agents uh
Andor sellers of property um we do get
calls from sellers saying hey how many
bedrooms is my system approved
for um and so with all that said i' I'd
welcome any
questions all right questions
representative
burough thanks for taking my question
I'm just more Curious uh what's the
recourse for somebody like who buys a
restaurant and find you know finds out
that it's not going to not going to work
according to what they wanted to do
um so so like like Mark said earlier um
their recourses they'd have they' they'd
work with a license designer um to
determine what their septic system um
was permitted for and then they may have
to do uh a new design to
increase the the number of seats okay um
so it's basically an unanticipated could
be major expense it could be okay yes
thanks representative
crley yes uh thank you um the question I
have is that if someone is buil if
somebody's going to open up a restaurant
or whatever whoever owned the place
first wouldn't they have a certificate
of occupancy which would list the
building that typically is is
a ordinance associated with a town and I
I'm not familiar with what the ordinance
might be um okay maybe the maybe the
sponsor of the bill could answer that
question and I can I can you can either
answer it now or or I know I know in in
sopy um it was it was up to the zoning
department to um determine the number of
bedrooms and or number of seats in in a
establishment however we did not have a
certificate of occupancy in that town
further question forther question yeah
when when I know when projects are
approved there's a subdivision approval
which is done and usually they get
approval from the state for so many
bedrooms on the proper and if a business
is open up they get a particularly a
food service establishment they get a
license to open up with so many seats
and that should be public
record that's correct and so there would
be the ability to you know I'm just
trying to figure out if there's a way we
could link that better so that because I
think if somebody is to buy a place and
he was told there 100 seats in the place
and the ctif oy says there's only 20
seats in the place it's that would be
deceptive
marketing would you believe so we uh for
all of the commercial approvals that we
we process all of those approvals are
sent to the municipality by email or
bullo how often do uh SE septic systems
need to be um looked at um what's the
word
inspected um so typically you should a
person who um owns a septic system
should be pumping their tanks every two
years um and some people will say three
um and during that time the the licensed
system okay who else representative M uh
thank you um it's been my experience as
a real estate agent that a lot of times
this information is not available for an
older home um if you go to the town they
probably don't have anything and so the
town says go to the state and a lot of
times the state has no information on
the septic system is there a way that an
inspector could retroactively determine
how many rooms should be uh associated
with it and typically it's the it's the
buyer who is the one who opts to have
the system inspected I sellers normally
don't do that right
great question um
so to answer the first part um the the
dees subsurface Bureau has an archive
system archive where um we go back to
1967 with the if there is an approval um
and people can request an archive review
to see if there is an approved
system if there is not an approved
system um and in inspection by a
licensed designer can be done and the
licensed designer can determine um the
the existing system components and the
uh either the number of bedrooms that
the system would support or the number
of seats that uh the system would
support for commercial
development I have another question oh
represent buam I have another question
about um certain bedrooms I mean the
amount the amount of uh bed bedrooms um
um in a um most of them that you're
talking about are Cottages camps um if a
person buys a a piece of property and
there's two bedrooms um let's say it's
on you know one of the designated Rivers
uh close to you know the the Waterway um
what's to prevent them from putting in
you know two other bedrooms is is there
a uh notification well maybe this bill
is what you need to let them know that
you can only have two bedrooms here how
is that prevented now you articulated
that very well um so yes this bill would
provide them with the information that
is necessary to determine what that
system is approved
for there is there are rules that
require um a new system design if you're
going to increase the use which is part
of that is if you're going to go from
two bedrooms to three that's an
increased load on your system which
application so I always learn something
new every day because I see a lot of
lakefront properties in my town which
they're all seem to say
three so the three would they had to be
design three cuz you're when you said
two two is the default the assumption is
that any septic system is only a two
unless you can document it it was a
three
is is two a default is that what you
said I just two is um depending on the
scenario two is is the minimum size that
A system can be designed for okay um and
then you know if it's going to be
designed for more than that you have the
the size is going to increase the size
of the system may increase so but if I
bought a house that was built prior to
and if and it seem seemingly only has
two bedrooms I can pretty much assume it
was a two-bedroom
system um if if there were no
documentation on file with the archives
and you had you um had a licensed
designer um investigate the lot
investigate what still have to design
yeah you would have to you would have to
uh hire a license designer to determine
what that lot would support and it may
support
more fair enough okay great any other
questions to the
committee thank you very much thank
you all right moving right along because
we're behind uh House Bill
Mons
thank you Mr chairman and uh good
afternoon members of the committee thank
you all for the work that you do uh for
the record my name is Chris muns I am
one of the four represent atives
representing the town of Hampton and
Rockham District
29 I was a member of this committee
between 2012 and 2014 and I'm happy to
be back with you today I'm here to
introduce HB 1320 of which I'm the prime
sponsor just within the last six months
we have seen unprecedented amounts of
flooding in our state not just on the
Sea Coast as occurred earlier this month
but in communities in the White
Mountains Lakes Region and mannok region
during June and July of last year this
flooding not only resulted in millions
of dollars of damage but disrupted the
lives of thousands hundreds if not
thousands of our fellow citizens many of
whom are constituents of those in those
of us in the
room sadly many of them were probably
taken by surprise they had no idea they
lived in or near a flood zone that is
what this bill is attempting to
address in 2020 the First Street
Foundation published a report entitled
the first national flood risk assessment
to find finding America's growing risk
included along with a written copy of my
testimony as a copy of the pages from
that report covering New
Hampshire in 2020 FEMA estimated that
29,000 properties in New Hampshire were
at substantial risk of damage from
flooding in their report the First
Street Foundation believes that number
is understated and estimates that the
number of properties is closer to 64,000
64,900 that is equivalent to a
approximately 11.1% of all properties in
New Hampshire and that Pro and that
percentage is higher than the overall
National percentage of
10.3% we have no way of knowing whether
the owners or renters of these
properties know that they are at
substantial risk of flooding for Renters
of property there are little or no
protections against waking up one
morning to find to your surprise your
water your car underwater in the flooded
parking lot outside your apartment or
worse yet your downstairs or basement
flooded at the present time the only
reference to flooding is a potential
risk to a potential purchaser of
property is a suggestion in paragraph 15
of the New Hampshire Association of
Realtors standard purchase and sale
agreement that a buyer determine that
determine the availability and cost of
flood insurance as part of their due
diligence a copy of that form is also
included with my written remarks there
is no requirement that the seller share
any information about pre previous flood
damage and or whether the property is in
a designated flood
zone there is however a requirement that
any buyer who purchases a home in a
flood zone and applies for a mortgage to
do so must purchase flood
insurance unfortunately this sometimes
is the first time a buyer learns that
the property they want to purchase is in
a flood zone since flood insurance is
expensive and becoming more so this
often makes it more difficult or
impossible for the prospective buyer to
afford the resulting higher than
expected monthly mortgage property tax
and insurance payments and they end up
having to back out of the transaction
they had invested significant time money
energy and emotional ups and downs
in committing to a lease or purchase
committing to lease or purchase a
property is one of the largest financial
investments any individual will make in
their lifetime the purpose of this bill
is to ensure the prospective renters and
purchasers of property in New Hampshire
have a fair and full understanding of
the conditions of the property they
lease or purchase as it relates to flood
risk and any prior damage caused by
flooding or storm events and the
potential liability they may be assuming
by entering into a lease or purchase
agreement due to timing constraints
encountered when the bill was being
drafted the original version of the bill
contained some drafting errors I have
worked with OS to address those issues
and have attached Amendment
01968 H which is co-sponsored by
representative grassy to my written
testimony as you deliber deliberate on
this bill I urge you to focus your
efforts on that Amendment rather than
the original version of the bill the
amendment reflects the original intent
of the
legislation before I speak to the
specifics of the bill I would like to
acknowledge and thank the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors and the New
Hampshire rental Property Owners
Association for their time and input
into this bill they were very helpful in
in identifying issues and concerns which
I did consider in drafting the bill the
amended Bill does two things first it
adds a disclosure of FL flood Risk by
sellers of property to prospective
buyers because the real the realtors
association was concerned about creating
yet another former writer that would
have to be signed and executed the
disclosure requirement would be added to
RSA
477 colon
4-a like the existing requirements to
discl Clos the presence of radon Arsenic
and lead by sellers of property to
prospective
purchasers these disclosures are
included are currently included in
paragraph 12 on page two of the standard
purchase and sale agreement if the
amended bill is adopted I would Envision
that paragraph being updated to also
include the required flood risk
disclosure the second thing the amended
Bill does is also require lessor or
owners of property to disclose the risk
of flooding to Pur respective renters
the rental Property Owners Association
had two concerns first they believed
that if any require was to be imposed it
should only imply to property with four
or more units referred in statute as
restricted property that is how the bill
is drafted second they also were
concerned about creating additional
forms and paperwork so the bill is
drafted such that the requirement to
disclose FL flood risk can be satisfied
by either including the the disclosure
in the app an a lesser asks a
prospective tenant to sign or through a
very simple separate writer the bill
also provides lessor who comply with the
disclosure requirements truthfully with
an exemption from claims of liability by
a tenant if the tenant ends up suffering
any damage to his or her personal
property from
flooding I am not suggesting that the
realtors association or the rental
Property Owners Association are
supporting this bill I will leave that
to them to discuss with you themselves
but I did want to highlight that I have
what I have done to try to address their
concerns and I do hope they will support
it or a version of this bill in either
case I appreciate their help in
educating me and hopefully creating a
better
Bill not included in the amendment is
some language I received yesterday that
provides some protections for owners and
or Realtors who may rely on third
parties to complete a flood ra Hazard
determination for form or flood
certificate for them I have also
included that language with my written
testimony and I urge you to consider
that as
well there's little we can do when
flooding occurs luckily there is a
growing amount of readily available
information about where the greatest
risks of flooding
are some of you will no doubt say that
it is up to the prospective buyer or
renter to do their own due
diligence I do not disagree with that as
with any large transaction it is always
best to do your own research but I would
also argue that it is incumbent upon the
owner of the property to share all
available information they have about
the property as part of the transaction
they are about to enter into the
legislature has certainly said that
should be the case with respect to
disclosures about radon Arsenic and Lead
given the devastation we have seen from
flooding not just recently but over the
years now is the time to add disclosures
of potential flood risk to the that list
it all it is also the time to provide
renters with some peace of mind about
the risks of damages from flooding they
may be
facing I urge you to recommend HB 1320
ought to pass as amended and I would be
happy to try to answer any of your
questions the key word there being try
thank
you okay represent
Willam um talking about renters uh
renting a piece of property that may be
in a flood plane or flood flood zone and
has flooded
um and and oftentimes if it has been
flooded there probably will be some
mold um which is a hazard so um I that's
included in the bill or I mean that's
that's what you're proposing is for the
owner of the property to disclose to the
renter that there might be some issues
yeah what the bill does is it asks a um
an owner to identify that the property
is in a female flood zone and also to
disclose any information that they have
about previous flood damage um
understanding that if someone only has
owned the property for 10 years they may
not have known what happened 20 years
ago but at least share information that
they know about know that they know of
so that the prospective renter or the
buyer goes into the transaction with
open okay represent
Burrows just a quick question would this
apply to a riverbank where there's been
erosion um where there's maybe not an
imminent danger of flooding I know give
you Anam a real life example my friends
bought this house on a river didn't do a
lot of due diligence and the at the
River Bank eroded the house was actually
in danger of of collapsing into the
river would this cover
it
um we tried to make the bill as um as
objective as possible so the key is
whether a property is in a designated
flood zone so if that property is in a
flood zone then yes it would apply if
not then this doesn't really apply to
that thank
you okay representa Amon
thank you Mr Sher thank you for your
well fought out testimony I think your
testimony is a model of how testimony
should be the way that you uh you
structured it um I think the first
question I had was how do you determine
if your house is in a riverine I think I
saw that um and and I think you answered
that with the it's a
riverine uh so I'm looking at page one
line 27 it says flooding properties in
coastal or riverine areas may be subject
to increased risk
does that word riverine have any
legal
uh is there um does it apply legally to
information I'm going to defer to my
comment that I would try to answer
questions um I I don't know I'm sure it
has some legal definition somewhere but
um it's not not what I I I don't I don't
really know how it applies here okay and
follow perhaps the chairman can my guess
would be if a stream that is seasonal
that you know because Ravine you know
like California they have The Valleys
that only when they're big seasonal
runoff so it's it seemingly runs only
when when it has heavy rain but that
would be my guess that certainly works
for me quick followup followup uh this
different question um you're requiring
that uh sellers of property disclose
that there's a flooding event uh and
also uh landlords to the renters what if
uh I purchase a house and I've only
owned it a year but 10 years ago there
was a big flood and then I go to sell it
not knowing that that happened H how do
you have a chain of custody of a log of
all the events so that the proper
notification can
happen um I I I think there's language
in the in the bill that talks about um
you know knowledge that you that you
have in the time that you own the bill
or own the property um the intent
certainly is not that if you bought a
property and own it for a year that you
would be responsible for knowing what
happened 10 20 30 years ago um I mean
what we're asking buy sellers to do is
if they have knowledge to share that to
buyer okay represent
Herbert um
how easy or or thorough or easy is it to
get the flood plane
information uh if you're an owner or or
somebody who wants to buy I mean is that
a difficult process I see a lot of
Statistics here but I don't know if if
uh I have I myself have never seen a
flood plane uh
map it's pretty it's pretty
straightforward and actually um State of
New Hampshire and I I think it's the
department of of Economic Development
has a site it's called a it's like a
flood M plane management site you can
actually go on there you type in your
address and it'll show you if you're in
a flood
plane
thanks can you I'm sorry I got
distracted to say that
again um the the state has a website and
and and I can I can get the website to
you all but I believe it's through the
Department of Economic Development um
and it's uh it's a flood plane
management um site and there's a tool
there where you can actually type in
your address and it'll show you a map
and it'll tell you what flood plane
you're in so all someone has to do if
they're going to buy a property or rent
a property is go to this web page and
type that in and and and find out
whether it's in a flood plane or not
that that's all that a seller would have
to do as well right so that but isn't
this what the bill is all about the bill
is about it it's it's disclosing whether
it's in a flood plane but also
disclosing any prior knowledge that you
occurred
okay that's a little trickier ain't it
okay
represent yeah that was actually a
follow-up question uh rattling around in
my brain is how do you prove that
someone had the knowledge uh let's say
someone had knowledge didn't disclose it
how do you know how could you prove that
they had that knowledge that's that
question what's the vi what's the
penalties for the violation of this that
is that is a that is a good question
um and I quite frankly can't give you an
answer to that off off the top of my
head well okay representative I'm sure
that there's there must be some kind of
you know if it gets to a legal case
there's some legal stand of you
know uh you know what defines prior
knowledge uh I I just I just don't know
what that is represent bullo yeah this
is a would you believe but I I I believe
that um the town planners or the
planning department would have um um
some of this information um so you could
go there before you purchase a home just
recent events um they they would
probably have it on a map because they
have several several Maps you know in
maybe more cities than towns but that
would indicate if there was flooding in
the past y that makes
sense representative grassy yeah Mr
chairman
um would you believe that on page three
of the amendment line 20 starts it said
During the period of ownership they're
responsible for that information and if
it was before you know that's all
they're responsible
for yeah that that is definitely the
intent it's only for the period that
they owned
it so you're from Hampton doesn't the
whole town flood when the creek when the
ocean um comes not the whole town but a
big portion of it along the uh along the
Sea Coast yeah and it's uh it's mostly
the areas that abut the marshes it's not
the the the the area that AB buts the
Sea Coast it's the marshes on the back
side yeah the back side and I I actually
have I have you know one one constituent
that you know wanted want to be here but
has actually submitted um online
testimony that um talks about the fact
that when they purchase their home they
were not aware they were not told that
there was any flood risk they were not
aware of any flood risk and the home
flood the streets around their home
flood continually now and that's really
what we're trying to get we're trying to
address is just provide own uh
purchasers with just you know
information so that they can make an an
informed decision
but if they had just pulled up some old
newspapers they probably would have seen
pictures of the of the creek Rising
multiple times in down that street when
they
have potentially if they were but you
know I believe I you know I I don't know
how that I don't know somebody moving in
from out of town I don't know if that's
is easy for them and again I mean I I
you know there there's no question as I
said in my testimony I mean I don't
disagree that people should do do their
own due diligence um but I also don't
think that it's right and fair that all
of that burden should fall on only on
one of only one of the parties in the
transaction I think if if the seller is
aware of the seller should be able to
tell the the perspective purchaser um
what they know of uh the risk
being gotcha okay yeah represent prelli
uh thank you for taking my question I
had a question about the process so I'm
a seller and I'm not aware of any issues
or problems so what are you a asking the
seller to do go on a website and look
and
see what and then disclose what how do
how does the process actually
work and you know what websites would be
acceptable and H how does that whole
process work um the the the bill lays
out starting on um in the amendment on
line 27 on the first page and it goes
into the second page what we're asking
the seller to do and we're asking the
seller to say is any or to to to answer
yes or no is any or all of the property
located in a federal emergency
management agency designated flood zone
yes or no and they can the seller can do
that by going by going online or as I
understand it there are um organizations
third parties that do that work and will
provide a letter of certif certification
to a prospective seller so that's one
question the second question is is there
flood insurance currently on the
property yes or no that should be a
pretty straightforward question um and
then C uh the third question During the
period seller has owned the property has
the property experienced any flood
damage from flood waters entering a
building or pooling making the property
inaccessible due to a natural flood
event such as heavy rainfall Coastal
storm surge tidal inundation or riverine
flooding yes or no um and then if yes
has a claim been filed again the the the
the sellers would know that if it's
happened and then finally is there a
FEMA elevation certificate available for
the property yes or no and again the
seller would have that
information that's that's all we're
asking quick quick uh follow further
question follow um so what about line 25
through
31 How would how would I understand that
information moderate flood Hazard
area um page two y those are those are
the definitions of a of a flood zone and
if you go to one of those online sites
where you type in your ad your name or
your your address it'll tell you which
level of flood zone you're in I think
it's called so it it designates that
it's different colors and stuff so it's
it's it that that's designated on those
sites and who that data is maintained
by um it's FEMA is it I I think it's
originally FEMA that maintains it but it
is a it is on on a on a website that the
state of New Hampshire overseas every
town needs to have you can go to your
town office they'll it's it's it's
available yeah every section
okay thank you very much
next card I I have a constituent I guess
here Joy dezer I guess she's from
Hampton they have her name I don't know
Jody
okay you have to turn the mic on and
pull that microphone up as though it's
your best friend is that good great okay
thank you Mr chairman thank you ladies
and gentlemen appreciate your time this
afternoon um I am Jay dener I am a
resident of Hampton and also a member of
Hampton's Coastal Hazard adaptation team
also known as chat and I want to give
you just a brief history of chat it was
formed in
2019 as an ad hoc committee to address
the needs for enhancing coordination of
flood related projects planning efforts
regulation and policy chat's membership
includes representatives of all
Municipal boards in Hampton the Hampton
Beach Village the Hampton Beach District
the Hampton Beach area commission the
town planner the DPW director and a few
resident representatives from different
neighborhoods in Hampton Chad has
developed 19 wide- ranging
recommendations for the town of Hampton
that are focused on increasing
resilience to coastal flooding and storm
surge some of these recommendations have
already been implemented some are in the
process of being adopted and some have
been incorporated into the town's Master
Plan update last year chat met with and
had several conversations with represent
representative Ms about his interest in
this legislation and chat has endorsed
his drafting of this
legislation I want to tell you a
personal story um my wife and I moved to
Hampton New Hampshire 25 years ago and
we bought a property that has wetlands
and Wetland buffers on it uh at the time
we didn't know that that was the case uh
we didn't face flooding issues but the
principles are the same between not
knowing about wetlands and not knowing
about flooding issues we came from an
area out of state that was high and dry
we didn't know what Wetlands were so we
didn't even know what questions to ask
um so we were relying on if there were
issues with the property related to that
for somebody to help us out to give us
some guidance none was
provided um fortunately it hasn't become
a major issue for us um when there are
wetlands and Wetland buffers on a
property most communities impose certain
conditions on how you can use Those
portions of your property um so it does
have an impact on your ability to use
your property so having that information
is
important
um while we most likely would have made
the same purchase decision as we made it
would have been so much better if we had
been better informed
purchasers uh the sellers or their real
estate State agents could have made it
so but nobody
did if you look at the 35 or so states
that already have flood disclosure laws
the most common disclosures are whether
the property has experienced past flood
damage or has flooding problems and two
whether the property is located in a
FEMA designated special flood Hazard
area or flood zone this bill is asking
that same information to be disclosed in
New Hampshire and representative Ms as
he has he discussed has worked hard to
ensure that the sellers and landlords
are not being asked to disclose
information that they shouldn't already
have and that the disclosures be done in
such a way as to minimize if not
eliminate any additional paperwork so
he's trying to make it easy as possible
to meet these disclosure
requirements some people have said that
the responsibility is on the buyer to do
their due diligence and that is accurate
and with this bill that will not change
they have also said that potential
purchasers or renters often double check
information given to them by Sellers and
landlords and that's a good thing to do
but that doesn't mean that if the buyer
are going to double check the
information anyway that those Sellers
and landlords don't still have a
responsibility to provide that
information to begin
with it will be because of these
disclosures that the buyers know that
perhaps additional questions do need to
be asked and
researched the point of this legislation
is to enable buyers and renters to be as
well informed as possible about a major
financial decision in their lives and
the legislation will also make some of
that information available to them
without creating a hardship for the
sellers or the
landlords people say that New Hampshire
is a buyer beware State and I think it's
time we update that narrative just a bit
to have it read seller beware seller be
fair rather buyer beware I think both
parties have a role to play in this and
that's what this bill is trying to
accomplish thank
you thank you thank you all right then
we'll get from the other side Sarah
realators good afternoon chair thank you
members of the committee my name is
Sarah Holland I am a real estate lensee
I'm also a licensed real estate instr
instructor from Plymouth and I am the
vice chair of the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors public policy
committee um we have had many
conversations with representative Ms and
we um are glad to continue those
conversations however as it stands um
with this amendment we are in opposition
to HB 1320 we're certainly not in
opposition to Consumers understanding
the flood risks of properties we just
feel that the language here um is
difficult to understand um and to follow
because it will require not just buyers
and sellers to understand this Rule and
regulation going forward that have
Realtors or lenses as their
representation but all property owners
who wish to transfer their property
going forward um we are definitely aware
we work in those communities that have
had all of the floodings in Jackson I
live near the peny in Campton um we we
work all over the state and we see the
devastation
everywhere um what we have passing
around is our purchase and sales
agreement as well as our property
disclosure and once those get around
I'll be able to share with you what we
Consumers copy it from represented mon
so great we can keep going so relative
to the purchase and sales agreement in
section 15 so this is after someone has
identified a property um for purchase
there is
um buyer satisfactory review of the
property disclosure the property
disclosure is our way to encourage our
seller clients to share all information
that they know about the property good
or bad and the reason that we do that is
transparent Y is super important um to
the success of the sale of their
property going forward the more that
they share about the property the less
likelihood that a transaction may fall
apart later in the process due to
something being
uncovered so when we get to the purchase
process the buyer does have to
acknowledge that they've received this
information from the
seller on the property disclosure which
is the second form that I shared with
you on page 3 section 9f the seller does
have to disclose if they have actual
knowledge that the property is in a
federally designated flood Hazard Zone
in addition in section um 9 L on page
4 they do have to the seller does have
to
share whether there has been a flooding
or a leaking event relative to the the
property although we can only encourage
our sellers to be truthful we know that
not everyone may be truthful and we know
that New Hampshire is a buyer beware
State I work both with Sellers and with
Buyers on the buying side the Mantra is
trust but verify we're going to look
into that property as much as possible
stepping foot on a property can share a
lot of information right if you're near
a body of water that may flood if you
see a flood event or you see some
crystallization in the basement you can
pick up on some clues that there may
have been a flooding event that we need
to look forward look at going forward um
we also have access to mapping systems
um that Dees puts forward that the state
of New Hampshire puts forward that our
communities and um FEMA puts forward so
that information is part of our due
diligence both on the selling side and
on the buying side because of course
there's a liability piece for everyone
involved in a transaction if this
disclosed the other piece is that the
language of this buyers are provided
with so much information in the sales
process that their eyes cross they are
unaware and as was testified earlier um
sometimes they just don't know the
questions that they need to ask um which
is why when we partner with them we do a
lot of one-on-one verbal um education
with them to talk with them on site at a
property talking about the pros and cons
things we need to look into um and
considerations that they need to make
whether they're moving forward when
deciding to move forward with a
particular property adding more language
in front of them that is confusing when
I read it as a real estate practitioner
having some knowledge in this area I
find it confusing um so I think we need
to think about that going
forward I am happy to answer any
questions represent
buo thank you for taking my question do
all Realtors present this yes and they
have to fill it out with the property
owner yes yes and every property owner
um will fill it out to different degrees
varying degrees depending on their
knowledge of the prop property
everything from if it's a foreclosure
and it's being held by an asset manager
no knowledge of what's happening on the
property some property owners are very
very thorough and will complete they
have great history they're great record
Keepers but most folks fall somewhere in
the
middle any other
questions see none thank you thank you
there we go good afternoon my name is
Elizabeth dery I am a Derm resident and
a professional planning consultant I'm
testifying today in favor of HP 1320 on
behalf of the Hampton Coastal hazards
adaptation team or chat which Mr deer
spoke to earlier I've served as the
coordinator for chat since
2019 um Jay commented on how chat had
come up with uh 19 recommendations um
many of which the town is taking action
on now or has incorporated into its
Municipal master plan one of the
recommendations requires State action
and that's what we're here today to talk
about I have
um a couple key points today that I want
to talk about and one suggested
amendment that I will follow up within
writing to keep my comments as breed as
possible the first is that there are a
lot of vulnerable properties millions of
people in the US live in homes that are
at risk of flooding and their homes will
likely get flooded again while the Sea
Coast faces additional Coastal
vulnerabilities flood hazards exist
throughout our state within flood paines
and areas that are impacted by storm
water and high groundwater there are
currently
7,261 National flood insurance polic
holders in New Hampshire and many more
uninsured properties located within
flood planes and other at risk areas as
we know from the New Hampshire climate
assessment flood vulnerability will
increase precipitation has increased
during the last century with the highest
number of extreme precipitation events
occurring in the last decade mean
precipitation and precipitation extremes
are projected to increase in the future
with Associated increases in flooding
rising sea levels POS significant ific
risks to Coastal communities and
structures such such as inundation land
loss due to erosion and greater flood
vulnerability due to higher storm surch
my second point is that flood
vulnerability is not always obvious even
if a prospective buyer or renter knows
about flood planes it can be very
difficult and Navigate to navigate and
interpret flood
maps if you live in a 100-year flood
plane and have a mortgage you're
required to have flood insurance so
that's easy information to
access without a requirement to disclose
past damages to potential buyers it's
extremely difficult for a home buyer or
renter to learn about a property's flood
history identifying flood risk in
locations outside of a mapped flood
plane requires site specific knowledge
which prospective buyers and renters may
to one report found that homeowners who
unwittingly purchase a flood prone home
are likely to encourage tens of
thousands of dollars in flood related
damages I can personally attest to the
financial and stress inducing impacts of
finding out that your new home is
vulnerable to flooding my house is not
located near a river lake Wetland or
flood plane but it's vulnerable to
flooding when it rains hard gutting and
renovating our basement accessory
apartment to mitigate water damage from
past flooding we weren't aware of has
cost thousands of dollars and until we
identify and pay for a solution we rely
on quick dams and shoveling water from
to prevent water from entering our
apartment door our tenant is not happy
with this but as you know the situation
in New Hampshire is very difficult to
find rental apartments so he's tolerated
it by denying home buyers information
about past flooding people can't make
informed decisions about one of their
biggest financial investments their home
my third point is that the coastal
hazards adaptation team is not alone in
identifying flood risk closure as an
important strategy to reduce risk the
natural resources defense Council
recommends that states update their
inadequate disclosure laws to provide
home buyers with the right to know
whether a home has ever flooded how
often what it cost to make repairs if
the home is located within a designated
flood plane and if flood insurance is
required on the property representative
months has not gone as far as including
all those items in in his proposed
bill um and that that's an an effort to
make this
um uh better supported to uh the
realtors in 2019 a poll by the
charitable trust found that 74% of
Americans support a requirement that
home sellers inform potential buyers if
a PL property has flooded repeatedly and
the Federal Emergency Management agency
which administers the national flood
insurance program has provided guidance
on disclosure policies as of its 2022
publication female reports that 35
states have en enacted some form of
legal or regulatory mechanism requiring
property sellers to disclose factors
related to flood risk about their
property fima reports that knowing the
risk of flooding is the first step
towards adequately protecting lives and
property and that knowledge can help
individuals families and communities
FEMA recommends that states take action
to protect home buyers in their state by
enacting laws and implementing practices
that require disclosure of flood risk it
notes that states with flood with flood
disclosure requirements often have
higher rates of residential flood
insurance uptake which enables
communities to recover more quickly
after
floods the report includes a summary of
items commonly found in disclosure laws
and or legally man mandated disclosure
forms which I won't read today unless
you'd like me to but I will provide in
writing um many of these items are
covered covered in HB
1320 I will follow up with my
recommended Amendment um in writing and
inclosing I would like to say that a
flood risk disclosure policy is an
important component of a more resilient
New Hampshire among property owners and
buyers or renters property owners are
the more knowledgeable party with
respect to past flood events and
awareness of whether a home has flood
insurance um therefore um I believe home
property owner should be responsible for
sharing this information
thank you to committee members for
hearing these comments and to
bill okay thank you very much oh yeah
testimony thank you okay uh Nick Norman
or
is thank you very much for the
opportunity to speak my name is Nick
Nick Norman I work with landlords across
the state of New Hampshire I'm the
government Affairs chair for the
apartment association and director of
legislative affairs for different organ
organizations of landlords across the
state I follow all new landlord tenant
law that comes through New Hampshire I
don't often speak before this committee
I'm often before Judiciary um but we
have a network of
3500 uh readers that we are property
owners landlords throughout the state
that we are in constant communication
with through our legislative updates and
the tracking of
laws uh I myself have been a property
owner since about 1991 as a landlord I
have 48 units so I'm I'm pretty
experienced as a landlord in
this in New
Hampshire um representative Ms uh
contacted us to get uh our thoughts on
the bill and I thank him very much for
that that was very good and very helpful
we had a good meeting uh together with
the Association of
Realtors I do have some written
testimony I don't have 21 or whatever
copies I would need but I do have an
extra one that I can pass out to the
committee and I will email it to the
committee so you'll have it so you can
relax a little bit on intense note
ticking because I'll I'll email it to
you there's many many many concerns with
the
bill um particularly in like Devil in
the details kind
of situations so we oppose the bill
certainly as
written so I'm just going to go through
several I can't take up your whole
afternoon but I'll try to highlight some
of the ones that seem to be real
important first off all of this language
477 real estate as it applies to
landlords and tenants is in RSA
540 so I think it's a huge mistake to
put this in a different statute than
what landlord tenant law is normally in
so anyone trying to figure out what's
the responsibilities of the landlords
and tenants they're going to be looking
in 540 and they're going to miss
this the other thing is that if you look
at the header of the
bill
on uh first line it says new section
notification of flood risk prior to sale
of real property it doesn't mention
landlord tenant it doesn't mention
rentals but it's thoroughly about
landlords and tenants so it' be really
easy to miss this if you were like
researching finding out what your
requirements are as a landlord or a
tenant we think that having the
government provide an easily available
website is a great idea that's mentioned
in the bill I think it should be easy
for someone to look up information both
landlords and
tenants we would Advocate that the
tenant are adults they can do their own
due diligence they can do their research
we've heard testimony several times
already that it's readily available
online you can just go get
it
there's a requirement in here of both
100e and
500e notifications anything in a
500e flood zone would have to be
disclosed and information given it seems
Overkill there's an odd thing in the
languaging the bill would encourage
landlords to not have an application and
not have a
lease
the way this is drafted the disclosure
requirement comes into play when you
have an application and when you have a
lease a lot of landlords don't have a
lease uh some people really don't do
applications you know they go by their
someone uh there's a concern that this
could affect liability uh for the
property owners if they're held Li for
disclosing something they may not know
and what does that do to insurance rates
Insurance
risks I can't guarantee you that I will
remember that there was a flood in a
property 35 years ago or 50 years ago
some property owners own property for a
long time so to to make something now as
a requirement to remember something that
happened 50 years ago I think is is
unreasonable
so there's some really Troublesome
language the way it's
written and section Roman I can't tell
you the page and line number but I can
tell you it's Roman 2 section g there's
a language that says results in damage
to a tenant's personal
property and there's also language that
says tenant shall only be liable to pay
for rent through the effective date of
the lease's
termination so if there's the tiniest
spe of flood damage then the tenant
would by this language be released from
all
liability if the tenant doesn't move by
the lease
termination then they're living in the
property with
statutory uh language that says they
don't have to pay rent they don't have
to pay any lawful damages they don't
have to pay the utilities can I just ask
you a question just not to interrupt you
you're speaking about the original Bill
and I'm speaking about the original Bill
thank you for that Clarity so and we
have the amendment in front of us but
maybe you have not seen the amendment I
haven't I have been given a copy but I
haven't had time to review it okay thank
you I I will review
it um based on what representative Ms
mentioned I doubt that any of the
changes I'm talking about are have been
changed on the
amendment so um you know that's totally
unworkable here you have a situation
where by law the tenant could stay and
now not be required to pay rent not be
required to pay any utilities or any
other lawful damages so there's no means
them this is in the original
bill I haven't had a chance to review
yet what page are you looking at what
page are you looking at let me see if I
well so I think it's it's fair that he
gives his comments because he didn't
have advanced notice of the amendment
right so he he's doing what he came
prepared to do and U that's a last
minute thing right and and I can in
email I can clarify that by looking at
the
amendment um based on what I heard I
don't see any evidence that these things
I'm talking about have changed but I'll
let you
know um um let's see section Roman 3H
which immediately follows
that says that tenant would be refunded
any amounts paid in
advance well it's not clarified what
does that mean does that mean
application fees does that mean utility
fees paid in advance that were prepaid
used a lot of lot of concerns with with
the way that's written the way it was
originally written is that the housing
PR provider would be required to give
money back to the tenant and the Tenant
no longer required to pay rent with no
recourse uh there's a very large amount
of concerns with this the way that it's
written and I'll I'll get that email to
you with all of these points and there's
more in there I just don't want to take
an enormous amount of time and testimony
when I'll give it to you in writing I'd
be very happy to answer any questions
representative post thank you very much
I just didn't get your name my name is
Nick last name
Norman thank you
yeah any other questions all right thank
you very much for your time thank
card put in a card and you can get get
in
line presented the bill oh you presented
the bill okay I'm sorry you're sitting
over
yeah um I'm I'm not going to I'm not
going to take away from any of the the
many of the concerns that um Mr Norman
expressed um I did want to clarify one
thing though that um I had referred to
the fact mentioned to the fact that
there were drafting errors with the
original Bill and one of the drafting
errors was that it did include as Mr
Norman said it did
include um rental addressing rental
property in the same RSA as um purchas
uh U sale property and that's one of the
changes that I made in the amendment and
you'll see that in the amendment
everything related to this the purchase
and sale of property is an RSA
477 and the language pertaining to
rental property is an RSA say 540 um and
I think that most of the other language
that related to to rental property and
the original bill was transferred into
that new RSA but um uh that would still
uh lead to some of the concerns that Mr
Norman had so I just wanted to clarify
that one point so we'll give the
disclaimer that all bills in Commerce go
to subcommittee and we we can have
continued discussion then thank you yeah
all right uh so we'll
call let's see here uh so we have two
cards remaining uh Mark K
cond
condro I apologize for that and you're
representing yourself you ask for two
Bill thank you so much U Mark condo
demat traki um I do uh I do support the
bill um just briefly don't need a lot of
time A lot's been said um just want to
give you a quick background found out
who I am I'm a licensed professional
engineer I'm also a licensed
professional surveyor uh I'm also a
licensed Insurance producer I've been
designated by The National Society of
professional surveyors as a certified
flood plane surveyor and I've also been
designated as a subject matter expert um
by FEMA to address the technical mapping
advisory committee on um directing uh
flood plane mapping and updating the um
the FEMA mapping uh coordination system
so I I just want to briefly touch base
on a couple of comments that were made
um we have to keep in mind that that
flooding is the most common natural
disaster to occur on a regular basis in
the United States and over 140 people
are killed annually from flooding and
you know in 2021 2022 there was flash
flooding in New York City and there were
people literally drowning in their
Apartments uh because they couldn't get
out the hydrostatic pressure of the
water would not allow them to open the
doors to their apartments and they
literally expired as a result of that
and we have to keep in mind that a flood
is an event it it is a catastrophic
event in most cases to most people
you're going to have annual flooding you
know in Sea Coast areas um in the Keen
area low-lying areas riverine areas um
but for the majority of flooding that
occurs it is going to be a catastrophic
event and trust me you will remember
that event when it occurs you will
remember when it happens um because
there will be substantial damage there
will be significant inconvenience um and
all along all that goes along with
it uh I also have a realtor training
course where I have a two-hour
continuing education course where I go
and train Realtors about flood plane
flood plane management um surveying and
Engineering as it pertains to flooding
and the transfer of property
and what the vast majority of real
Realtors tell me is they are not
interested in engaging on the disclosure
with whether or not a property is or
isn't in a flood plane and they simply
check off
unknown um and you know I honestly I
can't blame
them because again you're asking a
realtor to now delve into a very very
complicated subject and and provide some
specific Direction on a subject that
they may not be completely uh you
know educated in and that's another
reason why I provide this training um I
do want to dispel a couple of myths
though about how easy this information
is to obtain um it is straightforward
FEMA has a website you can go and you
can download every single flood
insurance rate map that is published in
the United States for free it is readily
available they do have a mapping
application and the state also has a
mapping a mapping application and it is
address and geocoded driven however we
have to keep in mind that there are
limitations to that information it's
like anything if you go to Google Maps
or Map Quest or put in an address in
your GPS sometimes it will get you there
exactly sometimes it will get you close
and sometimes it will not even be in the
same community so that is information we
have to keep in mind um you know there
is an entire cottage industry that is
related to flood and flooding and it is
a multi-billion dollar industry a lot of
it has to do with disclosing and
providing information on flood status um
you know representative Ms mentioned
First Street Foundation um I don't want
to get into that information cu that's
that we could spend hours speaking about
that um but the point is there's
information out there there's vendors
that will provide this information and
sometimes there's conflicts in that
information and that's what we have to
keep in mind and that's why this type of
acknowledgement or disclosure is needed
because as the property owner you know
you are still going to have a
responsibility of knowing certain
statuses of your property it is not the
job of government it is not the job of
the town to tell you to pay your taxes
or to tell you uh what your zoning is or
anything else you have a certain
responsibility as a property owner to be
aware of and knowledgeable in you know
the status of of your property and and
flooding should be an important aspect
of that uh I support the bill I
certainly support the amendment and you
know I support the language um for the
the liability also that that
representative Ms is including because
without that what will happen is a
realtor or a homeowner will simply go to
a thirdparty website put in an address
receive some form of certification
document or perhaps they'll go to A
lender and obtain a standard flood
Hazard determination form um from A
lender or an insurance company and that
may be incorrect there may be incorrect
or conflicting information on those
forms and at that point then it creates
a significant liability issue is the
real realtor liable for relying on a
third party is the homeowner now liable
for relying on the realtor who relied on
a third party and on and on and on so it
needs to be very specific if we're going
to have a specific requirement for that
disclosure and to have the words
truthful written in into that
legislation then there has to be some
aspect of of liability because you know
I know a guy who knows a guy that's
going to tell me that that property is
not in a flood zone and they'll put it
in writing and I can guarantee you as
the day is long nobody wants to be in a
flood zone especially when they're
selling property so with that I'm happy
to answer any questions uh provide any
other information or Insight
representative burrow this is just would
you know would you believe I just went
on the FEMA map and I put in my address
and they said the the information was
accurate as of 2013 so yeah it's you
know it's like anything right um
technology is great I'm not a leite uh
you know I I embrace and work in
technology um but I'm also aware of its
limitations and you know that's what we
have to be cognizant of uh like the
realtor said trust but verify certainly
an important um Mantra to live by by um
but when it comes to you know an actual
knowledgeable disclosure you know we
want to make sure that that information
is correct and
truthful represent
bam thank you thank you for take my
question um could could you tell me um
about the 100e uh floods and the 500
year flood flooding um is that
occurring 500 year is that occurring now
sure yeah so it's a misnomer to to use
the the term 100 year and 500 year and
FEMA has gotten away from that now they
use the term um 1% annual chance or 0 2%
annual chance which means you have a you
know one one one chance out of a
100-year potential of flooding in a
100-year flood zone um you know one one
chance out of 500 year of flooding but
again that's a measure of storm
discharge and you know in Manchester
there are multiple areas that are
designated as 500-year flood zones uh
those areas flooded in 2005 and then
they also flooded again in 2007 there
weren't 500 years in between those those
floods um but again you know it's a it's
a storm discharge it has to do with
severity uh and potential frequency and
discharge great thank you thank you we
for hello everybody my name is Tori
Bamford and I'm coming to you as a
resident of Dover
today I work in New Hampshire I've grown
up here and I hope to buy a house here
one day through my professional
experience I know how to read and
interpret a flood map that're called
flood insurance rate Maps I know what
each of the zones mean and what kind of
flooding properties in each Zone could
see I also know that this is not common
knowledge but without this knowledge I
wouldn't even know what questions ask
let alone where to look to answer my
questions the flooding in the last year
is something that you will not see
reflected in a flood map however signs
that you might see on a property such as
mold could be cleaned up with bleach and
some paint disguising it from potential
buyers and
renters recently the flooding on the Sea
Coast has been seen on the news but it
doesn't speak to the tremendous losses
by property owners and renters people
have lost cars washing machines dryers
water heaters and so much
more this damage means that flooding is
on the the Forefront of all of our minds
now but will it be in 6 months 1 year 5
years passing this bill will mean that
it will be remembered and adequately
reported when it
matters supporting this bill will help
people like me to know what to expect
and what questions to ask when investing
a home and I know that I will be able to
use my knowledge of reading flood maps
when I go through this process
but since this is not common
knowledge I worry about people who
haven't had the opportunity to learn how
to do this and even knowing how to do
this won't give me the full picture
please support this Bill thank
you thank you I'm having no more cards
repr sen grassy did anybody sign the
blue
sheet
okay so uh we have one two three four
five people's uh sign in in
hearing okay uh we'll open
up as soon as the clerk comes back I
will take this opportunity to let
everyone
know I have signed my Declaration of
conflict and that will be filed with the
clerk's office and that I have F I have
filed that I have both a financial and a
non-financial personal interest in the
bills the conflict is not the shape of
okay okay that's simple enough we got
three
welcome back to the Commerce
Committee thank you so much chair hunt
it's a pleasure to be back in front of
you again representative mea McWilliams
from South
conquered I've got some handouts that
are making their way around uh so I just
want to make sure everybody's got that
before I dive in um but on a brief brief
overview I'm the prime sponsor of House
Bill 1498 FN um and this bill is based
on a Colorado law that's uh very
similarly written uh there are a lot of
good reasons to have a Statewide
short-term rentals registry and I'll get
into that um but Colorado's concerns
were mostly law enforcement and making
sure that when local law enforcement
responded to a disturbance of the piece
or some other
concern it's very helpful helpful for
law enforcement to know whether the
property is a short-term rental or owner
occupied um so I'll just make sure
everybody gets their hand outs and then
it
okay
all right it looks like everybody has um
the handout so this is an article from
the New Hampshire Bar Association um and
it was originally published in 2023 I
think that a lot of this information is
still relevant this year
2024 um one one change after this
article was published at the time it was
published the town of Conway versus
kudri decision had only been um
finalized in the lower court uh since
May 2nd of 2023 the superior court of
New Hampshire has affirmed the decision
um on behalf of kudri so for those of
you not familiar with that court case
this was a a Conway battle about whether
or not someone could have short-term
rentals happening on their property um
or if it needed to be a special Zone
that said short-term rentals can happen
within this Zone there was a lot of
debate as to whether or not because the
town ordinance was silent on that it
could be included um and the court sided
with the uh the owner of the property so
short-term rentals continue in Conway um
some interesting things that you can
also pull out from this article I'm not
asking you to read it now this is good
reading for later um but uh in 2023 when
this was written only about 30 of the
234 municipalities in New Hampshire have
local regulations on short-term rentals
uh we are we are one of the few I would
say tourism economy States uh at least
in the Northeast possibly in the whole
country that is not regulating lure of
short-term rentals at the state level
we've been leaving it up to individual
uh cities and towns uh just from
Conway's perspective and to be clear I'm
from conquer but Conway has been dealing
with this and as an architect I deal
with buildings all over the state um
Conway had to respond to this somehow
because it's become a touris in Mecca
and many many many of the properties
that are rented out in Conway are owned
by landlords who do not actually live in
the property um so in response to the
Conway versus curic decision in May of
2023 where the supremor court affirmed
on behalf of the owner uh Conway has
since set up
a townwide rent uh rental license and
inspection program so they've hired
folks to manage this they've staffed it
up um and starting in September of last
year if you owned a short-term rental
you could either fill out a form uh for
$37 $ 5 and have a three-year inspection
or you could fill out a form for $125
license and a self affidavit with no
inspection uh but then you would have to
come back starting tomorrow the 26th of
January 2024 um to then apply for an
official uh permit so that was sort of a
stop Gap uh understanding that Conway
has heavily invested in doing some kind
of inspections and lure for their
short-term rental
really begs the question why isn't the
state doing that is it really only a
problem in Conway and I would say to you
that as someone who deals with an awful
lot of building Renovations in New
Hampshire no it's not just a problem in
Conway it's a problem in many many
different
communities uh this is the sort of thing
where we would expect to see some kind
of guidelines and not a hodg podge of
how our short-term rentals regulated um
and how do we track them is really the
big question so why this bill um number
one by establishing a registry the state
can regulate and enforce compliance with
local laws and regulations related to
short-term rentals so this can include
zoning safety taxes and Licensing to be
clear right now we do require that all
short-term rentals still pay taxes to
the Department of Revenue um and if
you're using a large vendor like verbo
or Airbnb they are collecting the
information about all of their
properties and submitting the taxes to
the the state but they are not
submitting that individual data about
the property owner's name and the
address of the property to submit to the
state and I think that that's really
where the Gap is when we talk about the
Colorado law where there was concern
where local law enforcement would really
like to know when they respond is it a
short-term rental or is it owner
occupied so this is about data
transparency and making sure that when
you're responding to an incident you
have all the information um so enhanced
safety measures a registry enables
authorities to to ensure that short-term
rental properties meet safety standards
obviously Conway is doing inspections
and I'm not proposing inspections across
the state but I'm telling you that's
where we're headed um in terms of Life
Safety there needs to be at least an
egress window from every residential
bedroom um short-term rental properties
need to meet safety standards fire
safety building codes so having this
information helps protect renters and
neighboring properties from potential
hazards also nuisance concerns local law
enforcement can use the registry to
address concerns related to noise
complaints parking violations other
nuisances associated with short-term
rentals having a centralized database of
rental properties makes it easier to
respond to these issues
promptly it also improves tax collection
property owners who rent out their
properties through platforms like airbn
ver Airbnb or verbo are often required
to pay occupancy taxes as we do in New
Hampshire registry facilitates tax
collection providing a comprehensive
list of all not just the big vendors um
all of the rental property and their
owners even if it's individually owned
it's a protection for renters renters
benefit from registry by having access
to information about the registered
rental properties including contact
information for property owners or
managers this helps ensure transparency
and accountability and Rental
transactions also Fair competition a
registry can help level the playing
field for property owners by ensuring
that all short-term rental properties
operate under the same set of rules and
regulations this preent prevents unfair
advantages for unregistered or illegal
rentals and finally data collection and
planning our state government can use
the data from the registry to analyze
Trends in the short-term rental market
town by Town year by year and assess the
impact on housing affordability to make
informed decisions about future
regulations and policies so th that's my
quick down and dirty explanation about
the bill um and the intent of the bill
I'm happy to answer questions and I know
there are people after me that will
likely test on this thank you represent
Sullivan thank you um I'm just kind of
curious about the enforcement so it's
pretty easy it's pretty easy
for for a municipality or even the state
to identify say a hotel or something
like that but if I just wanted to rent
out my house short term um what is
like what's the enforcement for somebody
who a doesn't know about this or B who
consciously chooses not to role in this
system or register I mean it seems like
that it seems like it' be really hard
for the state to actually monitor it and
particularly a bad faith
actor so we currently require everyone
who's renting out short-term rentals to
to pay tax on that and if you're doing
it under the radar or illegally then
you're avoiding paying tax on that and
when you get caught then you you're
fined for failing to do that so it's the
how you get caught is the piece that you
know generally it's law enforcement
responding to a noise ordinance multiple
times to one property till they figure
out oh this is an owner
occupied forther question for the
question uh so my other question is kind
of related to that what are the
requirements like how do we Define that
exactly because let's say I have my
house and I live in there and then I
just want to rent it when I go on
vacation twice a year to help pay for my
vacation does that have to be registered
as well that's an awesome question and I
have a bill to follow up on that after
this bill uh New Hampshire has not yet
defined find short-term rental across
all of our different sections of rsas
and so I have a contiguous bill that
addresses that in about 20 minutes stay
tuned
yes representative brows thanks for
taking my question um my question is
This Town of Bartlett is looking closely
at what Conway is doing and and they're
in the process of putting together
something similar to that so a lot of
the towns are going to saying this is
our job not the states so I was
wondering how how what your thoughts is
on that um I think that I'm trying to
split this so that lure goes under the
state but inspection goes under the town
um so things that have to do with life
safety like I said um making sure
there's a means of erress from every
bedroom would still be the town's
responsibility whereas the state is
really focused on lure because they
already have this data anyway when it
comes to receiving the tax money they
just don't have it split out by
individual property and owner but they
could it's just a different way of
tracking it and pursing out the data to
municipality representative M thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question what sort of inspections do you
envision the state or the municipalities
doing on what are essentially many
people's private dwellings for the most
part that's an awesome question um so I
mentioned earlier excuse me I mentioned
earlier that I'm an architect um so one
of the things that you need to do in
order to get a building permit is to
have an inspection
so every time you do a renovation to a
building you're going to need to get
that inspection to get your final
certificate of occupancy unless it's a
really small renovation it doesn't
require a permit but generally you're
going to need a permit so if you're
talking about um getting a license
through the town so Bartlett Conway
they're going to require as part of the
licensure process you're getting
licensed to have short-term rentals you
need to have an inspection by the code
official just as if you were having some
kind of certificate of occupancy
permit okay um what what was the feed to
to be registered with did I don't see
any fees in here uh I did not put a fee
in here I left it up to the Department
of Revenue Administration okay so uh I'm
going to shock
you I think this is a great Bill
except I want it
locally I don't want the state involved
the state right now it's more
complicated than you know because there
are people like me who've been renting
long before VRBO and home and in Airbnb
made the deal about the tax so I have a
state ID uh tax number already I've had
it since
2009 okay and I still have plenty of
renters that come in on that and then
and I hate the verbo and because I'm a
verbo because I have to pay the credit
card fees for the
tax R ridiculous I can't recoup that
it's outrageous yeah so we I actually
co-sponsored a bill was it last two
years now right that doing what you want
to do which is that allow each town or
city to set up a li have a lure and it
falls into John Hunt's rule of lure that
if you screw up they take your license
away shut you down and in that
lure you the town it because very
important the town needs to know who's
the contact person and in it is a
requirement that that contact person has
to be a New Hampshire resident has to be
in New Hampshire so that person in
Massachusetts who who bought that Ski
Lodge you know they've got to find
somebody
locally that's good for the reers you
know that uh that they get somebody
local who will be the person who will
respond and go shut that rowdy crowd
down someone who's respon keep you know
keep an eye on it um my fire department
absolutely came in and they measured all
my windows to make sure they were big
enough for people to jump out of not
that you want to jump out of a third
story Castle but you know they measured
that window okay so I I think it's fine
are you okay with just converting this
into a local Municipal one rather
enabling legislation for municipalities
to implement rather than have the state
and I'm sure Dr the last thing they want
to do is be tracking something that like
Li this kind of LC I'm sure they would
rather not do this so a couple of points
to what you just said um if it was
Senate Bill 249 that you co-sponsored is
that the one that stoed out for local
control was the bill okay I would have
loved to have seen that bill pass that
was an awesome Bill BR that solved a
large portion of this concern um perfect
one of the reasons I told you I was
going to surprise you yeah I might
surprise you too um so one of one of the
reasons that uh Colorado went at the
state level was because it was more
efficient in terms of staff to manage
the data at one Central Point rather
than over 200 different individual
communities and staffers so we're
talking about a handful of people who
manage the database rather than one
maybe two people at every single
municipality across New Hampshire so we
have a lot more staff engaged if we do
it at the local level but to the point
that I brought up earlier with
representative Burrows I do think that
this needs to be handled at both the
local level and the state level which is
why I've split out lure at the state
level where they're already getting the
data on taxes but I think inspections
really needs to be local and it should
be each town by Town setting that up so
if there's a way to you haven't really
cut out the
town part I mean you still the town has
has the same of bureaucracy if they
still have to do all those inspections
and do all those visits and do all that
stuff did did you visualize there was a
computer database that people could
access see that list or something I mean
I don't understand what you're what
you're because I have visual that each
town a person applies for this and the
town would have a file box and have you
alphabetically in that file box and and
then they would have to make sure that
the fire department's checked you off
make sure you're all up to dat in your
files and maybe you know on an annual
basis require you to you know update
your file so I don't understand how
that's any bureaucracy to a town to
implement so I agree with you um I'm
thinking an Excel spreadsheet I think
you and I are for generations for
organizations I know EXL better than you
do because I was with Microsoft I
actually I was I was with um lootus 123
oh boy oh how about vizzy Cal wow I was
the original spreadsheet okay so don't
tell me you know more about spreadsheets
we're not going to compete on
spreadsheets here but the idea is that
nonetheless there's a centralized
manager of the database which in my mind
is Dr because someone has to manage that
database and if it's just one manager of
the database rather than 200 some OD
communities right because they'd all be
inputting into a shared database let the
town figure out what they need for their
town let them I I would assume the town
right now had you know in terms of the
spreadsh sheets whether they do it
through their planning department
um in my case and I no doubt in my town
it would be the fire department will be
maintaining it right that makes sense
for Life Safety you and and because they
do the life safety yeah and they got to
know where the property is they got to
know you know and they'll know who who
to call if there's a problem so it's it
maintaining a spreadsheets a brilliant
idea so I think we are very close to a
consensus on what could work with this
bill it probably needs a bit of an
amendment but I
think P original bill yeah but I think
we'll take out
controversial piece in that bill which
was that that towns would be Pro that
they couldn't ban it all together that's
why it died in in Municipal County
government but now that we have this
Supreme Court decision we do we don't
have to sweat that issue do we now no
it's been resolved so now it's our job
as legislators to promulgate this yeah
perfect okay cool okay all right any
other
questions thank you very much
okay Mr
Wong it's always welcome back I don't
years good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Keen Mong tax
policy council with the New Hampshire
Department of Revenue uh the the
department does not have a position on
the bill um and listening to the uh
previous conversation I'm not really
sure um there's really much for us to uh
to bring up but since I'm here just want
to give you some um some background in
terms of the uh the m and rooms license
licensing uh for uh for operators of uh
room rentals um essentially so if you're
talking about um room
facilitators something like a Airbnb or
VB uh they are required to obtain a uh
M&R license with the Department um
their requirement is just to get one
license that that covers all all their
properties they they're not listing each
and every property uh that is under
their care uh it it looks like it's
going to be a administrative burden on
them because every time some property
comes into their field and or leaves
their field then they might need to
reapply uh for for the license so um so
current currently the uh owner operators
who don't who do not use uh a
facilitator will have to obtain an M&R
license on their own the room
facilitators would obtain an M&R license
uh a an owner operator who uses a room
facilitator would not be uh required to
obtain an M&R license um so this bill
seems to the the way we read the bill
seems to require um that owner operators
who use facilitators to still to to
obtain an M&R license as well as as well
as the uh the room facilitators having
to obtain an M&R license for each
location um so and then the other thing
that we noted on this bill is hang on
sorry oh yes um the um the providing the
information to the municipalities um if
this is going to happen I probably we
suggest that some additional language
should be added in there to specify the
frequency of that sharing of that
information uh and and how that
information is going to be shared and uh
to whom at the local municipalities that
this information is going to be sent to
um and um that's I'm here to answer any
questions so we could take all that
stuff away from me you you think was
great because I was just thinking that
that because I'm I'm I'm predate the the
deal call it the deal but uh so and
often I have months where I have no
rentals but I'm still required to file
with you right so theoretically all
these people who now don't do any filing
because they do they pay their tax
through the Airbnb verbo now they would
have to file monthly and tell you that
they didn't have any rentals when really
they did you're just the taxes being
paid a different way so that would
actually create a even more bureaucratic
nightmare for for you guys that that's
what we expect to um because all
operators are required to file an M&R
return even though they have zero
activity right um so those owner
operators who are using rental fac room
facilitators they are an operator and
then the and they have an M&R license
the room facilitators have an uh a
license as well so there'll potentially
be two M&R returns one being a zero
return and one with with value in it um
yes it will increase
administrative
activity excellent
okay any questions from the committee
members
seeing seeing none thank you thank you
got one more car card left Sarah Holland
from the New Hampshire reals who's
bill then we have another
different thank you again chair and
committee members um Sarah Holland new
hire Association of Realtors opposed to
the bill in its current form um we're
not entirely clear that the bill
achieves the sponsor's intent um and I
think that there as previously discussed
that there are some other bills that we
could probably bring back in form of 249
that would would um accomplish what it
is that she was looking to do but on a
local level um several years ago the
legislation amended RSA 78 A7 to require
room facilitators to demand and remit
rooms and meals tax room facilitators
are those entities like Airbnb VRBO and
other similar internet platforms um we
believe that the compliance of this has
increased and with it State revenues we
estimate that over $40 million in the
current state budget comes directly from
short-term rentals so current Law
requires short-term rental operators to
obtain a meals and rooms license and
also require short-term rental
properties who don't use those
facilitators so if I were to hire a
management company so to speak um to
manage my short-term rental company if I
did not do that I would need to register
on my own um and as uh previously stated
by the gentleman from Dr um having two
licenses one person so vbo remitting the
tax and then me as an independent um
property owner who has their property on
vo vbo um submitting a report saying
zero revenue is a bit of an
administrative and Reconciliation
nightmare um if the purpose of the bill
is transparency of which properties
Airbnb and vbo facilitate I think that
um the the bill certainly does not
achieve that either um and if we would
like to speak about
249 we would be happy to engage in
conversation about that and support that
as
well and I'm Bob Quinn I'm the CEO of
the New Hampshire Association of
Realtors had intended to speak but since
249 was brought up I thought i''d come
up just in case there were any questions
so okay I guess I guess everybody's all
set a thank
hearing
in the no it died in the house yeah just
so everybody know 249 died u in the
missal County government and it died
because it had a a little Sticky Wicket
attached to it and that was um to say
that no town could
rentals okay uh repr grassie you want to
hear me the remaining blue sheets up
great you don't have to sign the blue
sheet
you fill out a pink card you don't have
to sign okay we close at public hearing
1498 we'll open a public Hearing in 1635
and here from represented Mick
willans what a welcome opportunity to
see you again thank you so much CH hunt
it's a pleasure to be back again um I'm
the prime sponsor of House Bill 1635 um
relative to the definition of short-term
rental um so representative Sullivan
preempted me on the previous spill but
now we're here to discuss coming up with
a common unified definition uh and I
think that this may have been a piece of
the argument in the Conway uh case and
certainly something that we are probably
past due creating a unified definition
of um short-term rental big picture uh
we want to make sure that whenever
there's a lawsuit whenever people are
questioning is or is not my property a
shortterm rental it's very clear based
on our rsas it is or is not a short-term
rental um so the language that we're
proposing in this bill is that it's
offered for a fee right you've
got a group of units condominium
Cooperative time share owner occupied
residential home that's offered for a
fee so if your friend is living with you
it's not a short-term rental um and for
less than 30 consecutive days in a
building that is otherwise used as a
residence so vacation rental could have
the same meeting as short-term
rental um for purposes of this bill a
short-term rental Al is a residential
use of the property that does not
include a unit that is used for any
non-residential use so for example if
you have a mixed unit um downstairs is a
cafe upstairs is two apartments um then
obviously the the the unit that is
non-residential the cafe um would not be
considered short-term
rental um meals and rooms tax is
intended to Encompass the short-term
rental obviously less than 30
consecutive days uh and just to be super
clear hotels motels ins tourist homes
and other dwellings rented as short-term
rentals um are are meant to be excluded
um and that's a longstanding long-term
PR practice that New Hampshire has done
to keep hotels and motels and in out of
the short-term rental industry because
they have a whole different deal with
the state for how they're taxed
um we also have longer term rental so
vacation or recre recreational rental
units are rented for residential
purposes by persons who have no other
residents during part or all of the
non-recreational or vacation period but
are not short-term rentals defined above
so being very clear we're talking about
it's offered in a residential home for a
fee less than 30 consecutive days that a
building that is otherwise used as a
residence that's the definition of
short-term rental it's very common in
other states we just haven't actually
defined it uniformly in New Hampshire
and so that's the intent of this bill to
do just that thank you I'm happy to take
questions okay I hate to break the bad
news to you but it's it's worse than you
think because when I first got into the
sear ter rental the first thing I did is
I I said do what what is my
responsibilities and and then I looked
up the law the statute because I knew
how to find do that as a legislator and
it turns out the magic number is not 30
days the the magic number is six
months so 6 months and a day if you have
somebody staying in in a house for up to
let's say a certain you know to to six
months on the six month in a day where
you have been charging them Hotel rents
and you think about those motels where
people would live in them on the sixth
month in a day you were then were
supposed to refund all the rooms tax you
had collected on that person on that six
day six plus one days and uh norce to
say that that short-term Reynolds has
always always been considered just like
a hotel that's that is in our statue
that's that's the way excuse me that is
what Dr treats us as and uh that so when
we our license is not a short-term
rental license our license is rooms and
meals and when I fill out that tax they
ask me three questions question say did
I serve any meals no did I rent a car it
actually asked me did I rent the car no
did I rent the rooms or rent the house
yes and now I pay the exact same filing
as everybody in the in the hotel
restaurant business for we fill out the
same form exact same thing so there
really is no particular need for Dr to
have a definition of short-term rental
because in their minds we are no
different than a hotel
room believe it or not that's very
helpful um so one of the areas that we
currently have a conflict in rsas is um
in the building code would you believe
um in the building code it's not defined
at all as to how long one needs to stay
in order for it to be considered a
short-term rental or just a regular
rental um and so that becomes a problem
for uh for occupancy and inspections as
to whether or not you're doing a
short-term rental or if this truly is a
a house that's intended to be rented for
long term um so having some kind of a
definition would be helpful if you're
saying that the dr's definition is six
months and a day then that probably
should be the full definition so that
it's comprehensive across all rsas um
because where we run into problems is
where it's not clear and then someone
has to have a loss suit to have a judge
determine what's
clear yeah I'm not sure on that because
uh the issue was a life safety issue and
yes so that's when when my fire
department came and measured the windows
right and and so that that every room
had that Escape Route um that they were
doing that as though we were an
apartment house in other words they were
just you they were applying that same
regulation as any apartment facility or
anybody you know using Asic quote
unquote this is can be considered a
bedroom so anyway we'll have we'll have
more of a conversation it's ambiguous
but but but at this point this is not
the vehicle we want to use at this point
we want to use your other other bill I
think
so reent
bar I just looked at this quick but I'm
looking at 48 A1 definition they say
vacation rental or short-term rental is
uh one offered for a fee in less than 30
consecutive days and that's RSA I don't
know what the heck it is it's a a
universal citation what is universal
mean I don't know but it just
contradicts what you said never mind
never mind never mind well 48 a that's
not the RSA okay I'm just wondering what
this is is I I you tell us what what's
the the top of the web page this is what
happens when you Google
things all right we'll figure it out
okay any questions for representative MC
Williams seeing seeing none thank you
okay he is one more time do we have any
more bills in our committee that you're
okay good afternoon members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Keen M Wong TX policy council with the
New Hampshire Department of Revenue
um this has heard from the uh
conversation oh so just want to clarify
in terms of for M&R taxes uh Mr taxes is
collected on all room occupancy the
exemptions for the number of days is 185
days and above so the uh that's called
that's defined as permanent residence um
so anything permanent residence right
yes so anything less than permanent
residence be called a short-term there's
also a definition for short-term uh
short-term uh rentals in the uh M&R
statute uh essentially it's less than
the 185 days right um so um so when if
the definition is changed to um 30 days
um that would be a problem wouldn't it
it it's the exemption for the M&R is for
permanent residents so it's doesn't take
into account short-term rentals or
anything like so the language in there
so whether you define short-term rental
as something else uh it we don't expect
it to implicate the uh and change to the
M&R Revenue however um the I I I oh I
guess I need to say that uh the
department is does not take a position
on this
bill um and uh so but you might want to
and say that you really don't like it
because it could confuse people uh that
that is one of the concerns that we
might have is that um when when there's
a definition for short-term rental that
says it's 30 days or or less or or less
than 30 days and then when somebody uh
an
operator reads through our M&R statute
and says okay how is this applicable to
the collection of taxes um essentially
it doesn't really it might actually
confuse somebody say okay why is this
definition here short term how is this
different from a a Perman residence of
185 days and Beyond if the intent of the
build is uh is more of um
standardizing the statutes for the other
aspects of short-term rentals maybe it
for uh building building codes or safety
maybe have that separate from the M&R
statute and um since um we don't if it's
not really uh broken maybe don't
great right uh meals in rooms yes meals
and sorry meals and room STS apologies
and that's RSA one those Insider terms
yeah yes okay yep I'm here to answer any
questions thank you very much thank you
and thank you for coming to visit
word
thank you again chair and committee
Sarah Holland New Hampshire Association
of Realtors um again we do not feel that
the language of this bill achieves what
the sponsor intends I'll go very quickly
section by section as we've had uh
because I don't want to repeat what
others have stated section one appears
to only add the words that is otherwise
used as a residence does that mean if
the dwelling unit is not otherwise used
as a residence that it's exempt um or is
the intent to say short-term rentals is
something not otherwise used for
non-residential purposes it's confusing
to us so it will be very likely
confusing to others as well section two
currently any rental under 185 days must
pay the rooms and meals tax as
previously stated the only reason the
definition of a short-term rental is in
78a is to deal with advertisements of
short-term rentals having to display
their license number so we're not
opposed to changing the license
requirement from 185 to 30 days we're
not asking for the change to um but are
not opposed section three and four the
Realtors believe the current definition
is clear enough certainly not aware of
any issues which have Arisen which
require a change generally if something
is working and not causing issue then
we'd like to have it stay as it is
although we are open to discussion and
again we are more than willing to work
with the committee to discuss any um of
these bills here today any
questions I think we're all said Thank
you thank
you and uh the blue sheet we don't have
any we're all set with the blue sheet so
I will close the public
hearing
and
so Tuesday Tuesday Yeah Tuesday Tuesday
Tuesday Yeah Tuesday we're going to meet
a small room so you get to for you
newbies get to see what it was like in
the old days back in the old days back
days no you
know I my very first term I was on
science sci-fi as I called it and yes I
was up on the fourth floor I was up
there and that and that was right after
that that's when the burn when the fire
occurred so my my plaque my old plaque
on